so
welcome to legislative administration
it's nine o'clock
i would first ask for
representative simon to lead us in the
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you
nine o'clock we're in legislative
administration
we're going right down the list of the
bills in
chronological order
starting with house bill
this bill clarifies certain
qualifications for elected officials i
have one ping card
which is representative william marsh
i recognize
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman and members of the
legislative administration it's a
pleasure to join you this morning for
the record i am representative william
marsh carroll county eight representing
seven towns in southern farrell county
i'm here to introduce house bill 1007
relative to qualifications for office
since the ratification of the 14th
amendment to the united states
constitution in 1867
it has been established law that people
who engage in insurrection or rebellion
are ineligible to serve in public office
anywhere in the united states unless
excused by a super majority of congress
whether or not house bill 1007
eventually becomes law
this prohibition will continue to be
established law
for your information i just emailed the
committee a document from
congratulate research services on the
14th amendment
and i particularly call your attention
to the discussion on definitions
so what does house bill 1007 do and what
problem does it solve
under existing law the general court has
no authority to declare an office vacant
and call for a special election if an
individual is elected to office who is
disqualified by the 14th amendment
house bill 1007 simply adds this to the
list of reasons we can declare an office
vacant and call a special election
without house bill 1007
it isn't entirely possible certain
citizens would be unrepresented for an
entire legislative session if an
unqualified person were elected
are the definitions in section 2 of this
bill appropriate
the 14th amendment and its
disqualification clause were adopted to
disqualify confederate politicians from
holding office
any office
on december 20th 1860 the south carolina
convention unanimously adopted an
ordinance
peacefully separating itself
from the union
i believe the definitions as drafted
actually
accurately reflect the original intent
of the 14th amendment
to disqualify those politicians
i would like to clear up some
misunderstandings specifically some
things that this bill does not do
house bill 1007 does not make secession
illegal
that is already established law
on january 16 1833 president jackson
advised congress
the right of the people of a single
state to absolve themselves at will and
without the consent of the other states
from their most solemn obligations and
hazard the liberties and happiness of
them
president buchanan repeated and
elaborate on that statement in his 1860
state of the union address
and if there was any doubt approximately
700 000 soldiers and an unknown number
of civilians died in our civil war
establishing that the united states was
intended to be perpetual and that no
state has the right to secede
the united states supreme court was late
to the party but the 1869 decision texas
first fight
house bill 1007 would not prohibit
certain individuals from serving in
public office because they are already
so prohibited
the disqualification clause of the 14th
amendment will remain in effect whether
or not house bill 1007 becomes law
again this bill simply allows us to
declare a seat vacant
neither does house bill 1007 confer for
upon the house or senate the ability to
kick certain individuals out of office
part two article 14 and article 29 of
our state constitution clearly
established that our house and senate is
the final authority on the
qualifications of their members
the house and the senate already have
constitutional authority to disqualify
members at any time
that will continue to be the case
whether or not house bill 1007
eventually becomes law
without house bill 1007 a legislative
seat would remain vacant following
disqualification by the 14th amendment
leaving citizens unrepresented
i do believe all of our citizens are
entitled to representation and that is
why i ask you recommend this bill ought
to pass thank you and i'll be happy to
take questions
yes we have one question from
our clerk
i'm just wondering if you were going to
submit your testimony that you read or
uh yes i sent it to you by email and i
have one hard copy for your records
thank you
further questions representative simon
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um in the last
paragraph lines 21 through 24 you say
for this for the purposes of this
subparagraph insurrectional rebellion
shall include any action intended to
separate new hampshire from the united
states and aid or comfort shall be uh
shall include any action facilitating
such intent
um you made the statement that
regardless of whether or not this passes
into law article 14 section 3 of the us
constitution already makes it illegal um
to hold office if you've been part of an
interaction or rebellion does article 14
section 3 of the united states
constitution include that language
uh to the answer that question i would
call your attention to the document i
sent you from congressional research
services and the discussion of
but the short answer is yes i believe
the original intent of the 14th
amendment was to disqualify confederate
politicians from office whether or not
they actually engaged in in physical
violence as part of the army or not
quick
follow-up so
assuming that it it doesn't just for a
moment i understand you you say that you
believe the intent of it is to
communicate that but to say say for
example that it doesn't include this
language specifically
then
we would be disqualifying somebody under
this law
that isn't disqualified under article 14
section 3 of the us constitution
if we pass this and this language isn't
specifically made in in article 14. well
since i think your assumption is wrong i
i think the question doesn't pertain
i have one
um
why
this fashion and not a cacr
i don't believe we need to amend our
constitution in order to
implement provision of the united states
constitution
i thank you for your
your answer um
in in layman's terms
would
your definition
shown here
be violated if
a representative were to submit
legislation
or
in violation
if the if the legislation were passed
where is the defining line
the defining line is the house would
have to vote as to whether someone had
violated the 14th amendment and that is
well beyond my personal decision-making
to make
thank you so um
so you're not saying
that
merely the act of discussing
or
submitting legislation
would be the disqualifying factor
uh mr chairman if i wanted to submit a
house resolution to disqualify certain
peoples who may have engaged in those
activities from office i could have
submitted a house resolution to that
effect and i did not
thank you
anyone else
i have only the one pink card for this
um
anyone else intending to speak anyone
like to nope i hear
no comment so i will close the
[Music]
you
all right that's close enough as far as
i'm concerned uh i'll open the hearing
on
house bill 1033 and recognize the prime
sponsor
representative cordelli welcome to
legislative administration uh thank you
mr chairman and honorable committee
members it's a
pleasure to be before allegy admin for
the first time
for the record my name is glenn cordelli
and i represent the towns of
tuftonborough moultonborough and
sandwich in the beautiful lakes region
thomas jefferson said and i quote
to compel a man to furnish funds for the
propagation of ideas he disbelieves and
abhors is sinful and tyrannical
our statutes currently include that no
appropriation of state
funds or recipient of those funds may be
used
to lobby or attempt to influence
legislation participate in political
activity or contribute funds to any
entity engaged in these activities
simply
same provisions
to county municipal school and district
funds
i do not believe that it is proper for
any government entity to take the
people's money and use it to lobby their
elected officials
let me be clear
when we talk about government funds
we are really talking about
money that our constituents have sent to
their elected officials to run the
government
a 2011 gallup poll indicated that 71 of
people felt that lobbyists had too much
power
70 percent of republicans
68 of democrats and 75 percent of
independents
uh 29 91
opposed the practice of taxpayer-funded
lobbying
do you want to tell your constituents
that you think it is right
for their tax money to be used to pay
lobbyists
how much are we talking about in
taxpayer dollars i do not have a number
for new hampshire that i can give you
i do know that i have read that in 2021
there was an estimate from texas of 40
million dollars in taxpayer dollars
spent by local government for lobbyists
in wisconsin there was a 2017 estimate
of taxpayer-funded local government
groups spending more than five million
dollars lobbying state government
and in 20 exhibit 2008 there was an
estimate that public school
entity lobbying
reached 102 million dollars in the
country
it has been argued that this legislation
would prohibit elected officials or
employees from counties or towns or
schools
being prevented from testifying or even
discussing issues with legislators
that is incorrect
none of these people would be considered
lobbyists under our statutes
and the definitions in statute in
chapter 15 currently
none of them would be required to
register as lobbyists and therefore this
legislation would not apply to them
let me point however out however that
just as currently stated in statute
regarding state county municipal school
district fund recipients
could segregate
government funds from the taxpayers and
use other funds
for any of these lobbying
activities so the issue is not a
prohibition of lobbying
just the prohibition of the use of
state county municipal school district
funds funds that have come from our
constituents
the taxpayers
those funds to be used
for lobbying
i thank you very much for your time
thank you for your testimony um are
there will you take questions sure thank
you
i have a question
yes thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for your testimony today
um you talked about texas and other
areas is there a problem in new
hampshire
that you know of
is there a problem in taxpayer funds
being used for lobbying is that your
question in new hampshire yes
yes um taxpayer funds um contributed to
uh towns schools counties
and
probably in districts that i'm not as
familiar with but taxpayer funds are
being used to pay
groups that lobby
the government
thank you
thank you further questions can you shut
representative
yes
they're giving me direction today which
is a good thing
um thank you for coming in today the
question i have is when we have school
districts village districts
municipalities
paying salaries
to individuals such as
teachers firefighters people that are
members of unions
and they pay union dues
how do we separate
the salary that is being paid to the
teachers and the firefighters and say
that money came from counties towns
municipalities so that
teachers and firefighters are unable to
support a candidate that they would like
i think
the focus of what's in statute
now
is centered on
lobbying and
influencing
state
or local actions
in terms of political activity
um
[Music]
i i think there you have other statutes
that relate to whether they're
exercising
political
uh or performing political activities on
the uh time in which that they're
working for those entities be it the
school or the the town i think there are
other statutes that come into play um in
thank you but i don't think that really
answered my question i'm sorry um don't
be sorry maybe i asked a bad question um
the question is if funds are being paid
to
individuals at a state county level city
level town level
that are
paid by county town municipality tax
dollars
they come from
tax dollars
how do we say because we pay you a
salary
how do we say
you cannot contribute to a lobbyist
to go to concord and lobby for a
position because it's coming from
money from the towns how do we do that
um
i'll speak more
maybe
from the county side i'm a little bit
familiar with with that in that
taxpayer funds
go to
fund the
county operations
for
county government
to then turn around and use those funds
from the taxpayers
to pay for a lobbyist
to
have them come here and lobby on their
behalf
i think that's the intended
focus of this legislation and similar
existing
if
if members in that county or school or
municipality are paying
their own funds to be a member of the
union
and the union then
comes down here
i do not think that that would apply in
this
in this legislation
one further question so i just want to
make
it clear to me yes that this would in in
your opinion not affect
salaries that are paid
to public employees with town or county
money
for their salary or for benefits
from that salary or benefits being
sent to a lobbyist that
they support for their position so it
doesn't mean salary that's paid by the
municipality or the village district it
doesn't mean salary it's anything over
and above directly from the school
department directly from the village
precinct
to a lobbyist not the salaries paid to
the employees is that what you're saying
yes for instance um
let's say a selectmen or a
county commissioner
their salaries are
paid from
tax dollars but it is then their money
they have
earned or
presumably are earning their
salary and what they do with their own
funds whether it's contributing to a
union or whatever
is their own
choice
and would not
be impacted by this legislation those
elected officials are not required under
law
to be registered to register as
lobbyists and therefore um would not be
impacted by this legislation
um
thank you mr chair um so just to clarify
that point um in paragraph one it says
no recipient of a grant or appropriation
so salary wouldn't fall under the
purview of a grant or an appropriation
it would be packed correct okay my other
question is pretty simple one um when
you say physically and financially
separate um down on line 12
um what what
what is the scope of that are we talking
just separate bank accounts at the same
bank institution are we talking about
needing completely separate facilities
what's the physical separation right
i think as currently
in statute in that chapter 15
regarding state funds
you cannot just
entry to say that those state funds or
now county funds or whatever
are kept in a separate account
um
those funds that have come from the
taxpayers cannot be used for
payment to a lobbyist so it's not just a
bookkeeping
um uh
entry that um could be used but it has
to be actually separate funds separate
physical funds to pay for that um
lobbyist
follow-up i'm sorry i didn't ask for a
follow-up before
um
so
is this just a more complicated
um
way of essentially just keeping separate
books it's the same it's the same
organization
of uh assumably the same accountants
handling it um
what how are you
accomplishing what you want to
accomplish with this bill
um
those taxpayer funds
um cannot just be put into
account 100 and account 200 let's say
and 200 is the account from which
payments are made to the lobbying firm
um it has to be
actual separate funds um
whether they're raised from um
basically they're raised from other
sources other than taxpayer
that would have to be used for the
lobbying purpose
thank you
further questions
i have a couple
go anywhere great don't go anywhere so
it's helpful to this committee in the
past um when we were dealing with ethics
and and some of those issues to have
actual examples
so
just to follow up i think on on
representative roulard's questioning um
if we had um selectmen that wanted to
let the legis
committee in the state house
be aware of an issue
that is affecting their town
and they asked their town administrator
to come and talk to that committee
would that be
a violation under this no
if
[Music]
if a county saw
um
a committee in here dealing with uh
finances and and they needed
the committee to know about situations
going on in a county nursing home
um
would would
an official from the county coming to
the committee would that violate
this rule
no um or i've run into the situation uh
selectmen
talking to me in church about
legislation uh coming before
the house
and uh
there would be no problem in that either
well
i think you may get in trouble with some
of the people running the church but
that um
it is um it was after the sermon okay
um
is um
where do you see the line being crossed
um is it is it the
it's not salary
that that
meets the definition of grant and
appropriation and it's not necessarily
someone who is
defined
but
where does that
where does that issue
arise um
again i'll go back to counties i know
for many years
um
counties contributed to the county
association
the county association
did not
pay any lobbying firms
that is a fairly recent
occurrence
to my understanding
so the county uh paying
association dues
is is not an issue
but when that money then is paid
for
someone
hired as a lobbyist to lobby the
legislature that's where the problem
happens
thank you for your testimony
one further question
thank you mr chairman following up on
your question um
isn't it typical for an organization to
hire a lobbyist on their behalf to come
in
um thank you for the question um i'm
sure many do
and
they would not
be prohibited from
doing that it's just that they would
have to use funds other than
taxpayer originated funds in order for
that
follow-up
okay so going back to the county issue
we're paying into the accounting
organization and the county
hire a lobbyist to come on their behalf
on perhaps the nursing home or the jail
or something
that's taxpayer money that's used now
isn't it
uh taxpayer money
now
um
be going to that
organization
yes
the the issue would arise when
the organization then turns around and
uses those
funds because they originated with the
taxpayer
to hire someone to lobby the legislature
if they use
they could go out and
do a bake sale
and use those funds to pay for the
lobbyists
or funds
from any other source other than the
taxpayer
going back thank you going back to
representative
questions
so these organizations are paid by tax
dollars that is how they make their
money so if they
need to hire a lobbyist for one of their
issues
doesn't the money naturally come from
their source
i'm sorry
i
um
uh
they would have to find another source
of income
another revenue stream to pay for that
lobbyist
thank you
you set can you turn that on again i
think we're set right
thank you for your testimony
representative thank you for uh hearing
me
uh
next up i have
yep i have
three pink cards um the chair will
recognize
and i'm not sure from the organization
um jason henry from
nhac
if you could
i'm assuming association of counties
yes sir ah
welcome to legislative administration mr
henry
um
when you're ready
thank you appreciate you uh allow me to
be here to speak today i do believe an
email a letter was sent to you by kathy
stacy who is our legislative chair for
new hampshire association of counties
speaking on behalf of
position of all counties
i won't go into full detail on that
instead i'll go with
my
experiences with the county
so legislative advocacy on our end um
has been it's very important on
any any group
there are 1200 bills plus a year that to
keep track of that you're asking
department head like me iran rockham
county jail to try to keep track of and
know what's going on and be here all the
time where advocacy can be here track
the bills for us and also make our
voices known
we have found that actually it's
a much better mechanism of our time and
money-wise
the representative talked about the
association of counties and money going
to them and then to a lobbyist firm
so in the past just to give us past
history the association county had a
full-time attorney
which actually cost us more money than
what we're doing now to be down here on
behalf of lobbying for us
and being here our eyes and ears and we
would still come down and testify as
subject matter experts
as we needed and contact but limit our
time so we have found that has saved
time and money there in my tenure i've
also found
well some bills are put in in good faith
um one bill is counterintuitive to
another bill one bill affects another
bill and if we didn't have some sort of
representation
that could keep track of these things
i have personally seen the amount of
money that we have saved counties and i
also sit on the school board as well and
school board the money that we've saved
and not because of ill will somebody
putting something in it just doesn't
understand how it affects something else
and having our voices heard but to be
here all the time and representing that
all the time
it's still going to be going to be a
full-time position at
some level somewhere so pulling our
money together and having an
organization help us is very beneficial
and very financially responsible because
it costs a lot less than the amount of
money that we've saved throughout the
years
and i'll leave it there because you do
have my do have the letter from
association accounting
thank you um are you willing to take
questions if we have any yes sir
we have one representative expedia
thank you for taking my question thank
you mr chair um
so would you say that the times that we
as a legislature meet are kind of
inconvenient because you're out there
doing stuff during the day would you
find it a little inconvenient to have to
come in yeah so
i have a full-time job running running
at jail so yes it's for different people
different days and the multitude of
bills that
that we that we'd have to take a look at
is very um
cumbersome yes
i think i see none thank you very much
thank you i appreciate it
um
also signed up to speak
is margaret burns
welcome to legislative administration
you signed up for three minutes
all right good morning thank you
everyone my name is margaret burns i'm
the executive director of the new
hampshire municipal association and we
are here this morning in opposition to
house bill 1033
house bill 1033 seeks to affect the
ability of local officials to engage in
the legislative process and to lobby
their legislators this legislation
affects many different organizations in
new hampshire the association of police
chiefs the new hampshire association of
counties the water works association the
assessing officials the building
officials and the list goes on and on
it is also incredibly far-reaching in
its application the legislation says no
recipient of a grant or appropriation
this could mean that it would apply not
only to organizations like the assessing
officials and the building officials but
it could also apply simply to non-profit
organizations that receive
appropriations from local governments
which is pretty common at the local
government level it could also be even
applied to businesses that receive funds
or contract with municipalities because
that could count as an appropriation
received from a local government
proponents of this legislation may argue
that paragraph two creates a sufficient
exemption
it states that the funds must be
physically and
financially separated in order for the
for the organization to be able to lobby
however this physical and financial
separation creates an administrative
burden for very small organizations that
not only provide education and training
for local officials but may also provide
lobbying services as part of their
organization
financially separated may be a clear
distinction separating in bank accounts
but the question of what it means to
physically separate these funds in order
to comply with the statute is extremely
unclear
when local governments pay dues to
organizations like an hma like the
building officials like the tax
collectors association they are aware
that as part of the package they are not
only getting the training the resources
the publications and the other support
that are provided but they may also be
getting lobbying and advocacy services
there was
testimony earlier as well that i wanted
to address one of the items brought up
was that it is not known or that it is
unclear how much money is spent on you
know how much taxpayer money is spent at
the local level on lobbying
speaking for nhma
i'm a registered lobbyist and executive
director of the organization we have two
other registered lobbyists
as required by law we report quarterly
how much is expended and how much on
revenue is used on lobbying services we
report that to the secretary of state's
office and that information is publicly
available and that is already required
finally
there were some questions asked earlier
good questions about how this
legislation would affect for example a
local official a town administrator or a
select board member who wishes to come
and speak to a committee
and provide a position
or wishes to send a letter to that
committee and if this legislation
doesn't affect that why is this
legislation so problematic and i'd like
to address that
there are approximately 300 bills and
i'm just speaking from the new hampshire
municipal association's perspective
there are about 300 bills a session
that affect local government
municipalities have realized that it is
more cost effective for them to be a
member of an organization that not only
follows those bills keeps them up to
date on those bills but also goes to the
legislature on their behalf to speak to
committees about what bills are positive
for local government what bills are
negative for local government and also
to simply work with legislators and
committees to understand how the bills
impact local government and so for that
reason municipalities have seen this as
a more cost effective way to be engaged
in their legislative process rather than
to send every to every hearing to send
local officials elected or appointed to
be part of that hearing and to testify
so that is one of the primary reasons
that municipalities see the value and
the cost benefit in being part of
organizations like the new hampshire
municipal association and the many other
organizations that come before
legislative committees on municipal
issues
that concludes my testimony and i am
happy to take any questions thank you
for your testimony are there further
questions i see one representative
roulard
thank you for coming today uh i think
and correct me if i'm wrong
the gist of your testimony today
is that
we really should leave this to the towns
you municipalities to deal with what is
most cost effective and efficient for
them
and not pass statewide legislation am i
right on that i don't think i could have
said it any better yes that is correct
and indeed the spending of funds on
being a membership a member of an
organization like nhma or any other
organization
is part of the budget and in most of our
municipalities that budget is passed by
the voters at town meeting because
that's our primary form of government
and indeed the decision not only should
be left at the local level for
municipalities but it should be left at
the state level for the state and the
state has been in
prior years and and i believe in current
times the state has seen fit to be part
of the national conference of state
legislatures which is a bipartisan
lobbying organization that many
legislators legislatures around the
country
are members of because they see the
value and having advocacy at the federal
level
thank you
um we currently have in statute section
15 colon 5.
that says
no recipient of a grant or appropriation
of state funds may use the state funds
to lobby or attempt to influence
legislation participate in political
activity or contribute funds to any
entity
engaged in these activities
i'm assuming
and and
you've correctly pointed out that the
way
they circumvent or
work with that
provision is to physically separate the
funds so they're they're not using state
funds in order to pay for those lobbying
activities
so
where the goal is to not
have
state funds
pay for
influencing
what would be wrong than with
any of the other entities that are
mentioned in the bill county municipal
school district to also be able to
separate or segregate what are state
funds and what are funds from the
taxpayers of those other entities
to to do the same thing that we're
currently doing with just state funds
thank you i appreciate that question i
can't speak to what the state is doing
with in the means of separating its
funds for the purpose of lobbying i i
can't speak to the state's own physical
and financial separation of state funds
for that purpose
what i can speak to is the
administrative burden that it would put
on the many different small local
government related organizations that
would be affected and that would be
required to financially and physically
separate their funds again financially
separate i assume means separate bank
accounts i think we can all get behind
that definition and we know the
difference between a mere bookkeeping
entry and an actual separate bank
account
uh physically separate is something that
is less clear to me what is meant by
that and so when i think about the
dozens of local government entities
local government organizations across
the state tiny organizations putting
nhma aside tiny organizations that are
run by municipal officials who volunteer
their time to run organizations that
provide training that provide workshops
and that also may lobby
that burden on them to do the financial
and physical separation of
revenue that comes in from
municipalities is going to effectively
shut them down because the ability to
comply with that um is simply an
administrative burden that seeks to shut
them down and to stop them from doing
what they're doing
uh thank you for your
answer i i'm not sure
um
i'm not sure i understand completely
it's not
it's my understanding
that
it's not how the state separates their
funding
it's how these entities that receive
state funding currently
cannot use those funds
for lobbying
activities so
a school department if they receive
state money
they must physically have that money in
a separate checking account
and can't use those dollars to pay
for lobbying activities back to the
state
that's how it that's how it's currently
understood
by me
um
and that's my reading of this
so
i guess
to to restate my question
if
if those entities currently are are
having to separate or segregate
physically
state funds to do that
why would they not why would these other
four
entities not also be able to segregate
the funds that come from
those entities in order to pay for that
that lobbying elsewhere thank you i i
understand um your question that is not
my understanding of current law and of
course i do not represent school
districts so i can't speak to that
particular scenario that you're giving
me so i apologize to that um but my
second point that applies somewhat to
your question when i think about the
other organizations in the state that
would be affected like assessing
officials building officials they
receive
all most if not all of the dues that
they receive in order to be functioning
organizations
they are entirely
from municipalities they are entirely
municipal funds that go to those tiny
organizations to allow them to exist and
to do what they do so in scenarios like
that
it is not possible for them to separate
out municipal or taxpayer funds in order
to lobby they would simply be unable to
lobby
and that means simply be unable to send
someone on behalf of the organization
and the municipal officials that are
part of that organization to the
legislature to do exactly what i'm doing
here to talk about legislation with the
committees to talk about how it could be
fixed to have a better impact on local
government so so that's how it would
affect the many organizations in the
state like that
uh thank you for your answer and i do
understand
they still would be able to
directly influence
themselves they just wouldn't be able to
use utilize the funds
to hire a firm to speak for them is that
fair to say i believe that's correct and
in many circumstances that is the most
cost effective way for them to have
their voice heard thank you thank you
uh
one more pink card i have um which is
um ken robershaw um town of northfield
town administrator i believe yes welcome
to legislative administration thank you
mr chairman thank you thank you
uh
committee members for allowing me to
speak here today
um my name is ken robinshaw i spent 19
years in
in the county operations and i spent the
last two years in a town operation so
i know both sides of the operations
but i'm here to testify today in
opposition of house bill 1033
this bill in its entirety is wrong and
goes against all that new hampshire
towns stand for and represent
each town in new hampshire is unique and
each town has its own strengths and its
own weaknesses
the town of northfield is no different
than an ordinary new hampshire town
the town of northfield has a budget
committee
that scrutinizes each appropriation in
each expenditure
the town on lower field has three
selectmen
that review each appropriation and each
expenditure
the town of norfield has a town meeting
each march and at that time meeting the
residents vote for all appropriations
and establish a budget
that the town must live within
these are the people that should decide
how their tax dollars are spent in their
towns
the
the selectmen
uh have voted in opposition of hb 1033
as we believe this legislation will
place an undue burden on towns
as it was stated today there were over
300 bills that that
are monitored
the town of northfield utilizes new
hampshire and missile association to
advocate on behalf of the town of
norfield which saves us time and also
money
the town of norfolk also believes that
through
through the budget process
that if the town did not want to spend
the money on on association then they
wouldn't spend the money on the
association
most of this stuff has already been said
today
i don't like being last because
everything else has been said so
um
northfield's a small town
we have a population of less than five
thousand
um
it's hard to uh to follow each bill
um we use the new hampshire municipal
association to help us with that and
it's a great asset
and the selectmen asked that
you all vote to expedite to legislate
this bill
thank you thank you
any questions for mr
robershaw
representative roulard
thank you
um
you're not the only person that's kind
of danced around this a little bit
others have as well
are you saying that the small towns the
smaller towns would more particularly be
affected by this
because they would have to figure out
another way
to get the information
that larger towns or cities would be
able to get because they have maybe
financial
means or donations or whatever it is
that can come into them
are you saying that in order for small
towns to be able to understand what's
going on at the state level they would
have to hire somebody independently to
do that where now they pull their funds
and they have those funds
distributed to individuals that are in
fact lobbyists to provide information to
them on how they should govern their
towns that is that that's a good example
and um i think that town of northfield i
mean we have
limited staff and it's getting harder
and harder to fill our positions
um
i think that
the municipal association provides more
than just lobbying they provide
education they provide conferencing they
provide training
um
and so
i i utilized that organization quite
frequently
follow up
you know we have in my town
um goffstown
uh we have a lot of different volunteers
and a lot of them are attorneys me
included
and we do volunteer our expertise and
our time so i although i can appreciate
that small towns may have to go out and
hire people to help them
um a lot of times there are volunteers
that are able to do that so i i do
understand what everybody is saying
about pooling their funds and i can
appreciate that but i just wonder if the
small towns especially the borders the
selectmen the group that you're um part
of if they have actually thought about
perhaps getting volunteers in their town
to help them and advise on that
um we currently have um
openings on on all our boards
we
didn't have enough for a cip committee
this year so you know volunteerism is
not what it used to be
in town northfield anyways true thank
you
thank you any further questions
representative simon
um
so i i realize that this information on
the whole has to be um given to the
secretary of state report to the
secretary of state um but i would find
it helpful to know if you know what your
town pays the lobbying service for their
service
a lot of the testimony is i think
rightfully so that you know it's placing
a burden on small towns that makes it
difficult and it would be helpful to
know
financially what kind of numbers we're
looking at how much does it cost you for
that service you know
for the new hampshire municipal
association it's about 5 000 a year
no further questions i have one
um does northfield i say this as a
resident of northfield
does northfield have
sources of income that are not
um as i was
i was sitting here listening and trying
to think and i can't think of any really
um
i mean we
there are there are uh funds that um
other towns have mentioned in the past
that come from
even from
interest income that comes from cemetery
fund anything like that it's my
understanding and i'm i'm wondering if
it's your understanding if that money by
definition from this law if this were to
pass
that money could be placed into a
separate
distinct checking account and that money
could provide
the five thousand dollars that uh was
just stated
as
the dues for a municipal association
and and none of this would then apply
everything would stay the same or
and i'm not sure if
maybe you know if
if new hampshire and i should have asked
new hampshire municipal association
representative
or executive director if
if there is a line item for lobbying so
that a town could purchase
all of the other services that you
mentioned that northfield uses other
than lobbying i don't know if that's
an option but but i'm wondering if
if there is a way
that you could work with this law by
segregating those funds that came from
other sources other than direct taxation
um i don't want to answer for the
association so i'm not gonna answer that
other question um but as far as our fees
you know it's very small i mean interest
on on our checking accounts you know ten
dollars i mean so it's not a lot of
money
uh most of our most of our income is you
know driven by taxes so
yeah
i'm going to follow up on something our
here just asked you he talked about a
little bit about lobbying and what was
paid and whether there was a line item
for that with regard to the new
hampshire municipal association
you pay them about five thousand dollars
a year
for their services does that also
include individual legal services to
you versus lobbying
i'm sorry i don't follow your question
the money that you pay new hampshire
municipal association like five thousand
give or take
is that five thousand solely for
lobbying or is it for answering legal
questions that you have and defending
the town and providing advice to you
it's all inclusive so that's also
included in the 5000 yes follow up sorry
i was wrong on that
um do you know the do you know the
breakdown for lobbying and legal fees
you do not
thank you
brother
seeing none thank you very much
i i lied as well uh there was one
additional card under another pile of
pink cards so i will call barrett
christina new hampshire school boards
association
and welcome you to the legislative
administration
thank you very much mr chair thank you
members of the committee my name is
barrett christina i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire school
boards association just by way of
example uh miss burns from the municipal
association spoke a few minutes ago were
sort of their counterpart on the uh on
the school side we're a voluntary
organization we have about 161
school boards that pay dues across the
uh from across the state that pay dues
to nhsba
i don't have a lot to add i think most
of my testimonies are already been
covered by the by the previous speakers
um just a couple points that i that i do
would would like to make though um i did
some legislative history of rsa 15 5 in
its current form i believe it was from
2006 when the current iteration of this
bill um
ran through the legislative process the
legislative history is is not helpful
it's not conclusive by any means this
language in rsa 15 5. seems to be
included in a very comprehensive bill
that i think started out with like um
ethical standards for the um the um
the governor's branch of office or the
governor's office things of that nature
so that's not very instructive but um i
think it isn't instructed for what the
intent of the statute really is intended
to mean though but i think it is helpful
that when this statute became law in
organizations such as nhma and the
school boards association the counties
association
we were not tracked as being followed
under this law i think if the intent of
this law was to include or nonprofit
organizations such as nhsba the
municipal association some of the other
associations whoever put that language
in the bill would have been on top of
these sorts of associations to make sure
that we were following these provisions
in terms of segregating funds and things
of that nature
the other aspect that i would like to
make as well too and i believe ms burns
made this
we have to be very mindful um that
public bodies engage with
for-profit businesses
trash removal electrical services
internet uh it's my assumption that some
of those organs though some of those
private companies also engage in
lobbying so
what percentage of of of your cable bill
or your electric bill that you're paying
to a company is being used for lobbying
services in front of this body when
you're paying that bill with public
money i think would also be very
confusing
uh relative to um
sort of the the sharing of services and
and and having uh individual public
bodies be able to have a voice here at
the legislature there are currently 100
bills in house education alone um it
would be unreasonable to ask school
board members to
find time to come down to speak on every
bill
to have the expertise or knowledge to
speak on every bill
how many times do we have a bill
scheduled at 10 30 and it's noon before
we finally get to it these are people
with jobs and families and kids and
child care and all those sort of all
those other issues so it
makes sense to pay a professional
organization who has the background and
information and knowledge and history
and expertise to be able to speak to the
legislature
on the on on behalf of the public body
or on behalf of a certain entity or
organization
i think those are all the the questions
i have um to address some of the
questions um that this body may have had
representative roulard i believe you
asked the individual from from
northfield about the dues to nhma and
how much of those dues are particularly
used for quote unquote lobbying um
so again a school board will pay nhsba
a certain a certain fee and just for
your own background
high is manchester their dues are about
7 200 hours per year and our low is
probably 800 to 1 000 a year for maybe
like waterville valley or ellsworth with
with very few students just to give you
a range
um so the dues
don't pay for lobbying per se it's
bundled packages we provide
legal advice we have a staff attorney
who answers legal questions from school
board members and superintendents all
day works with policy policy work right
to no law questions things of that
nature
um we uh um other services that we
provide trainings um we do probably 12
to 15 webinars a year and then we do
probably 50 to 80 individual trainings
every year where myself or my staff
attorney will visit a local school
district and do a training on roles and
responsibilities right to no law
collective bargaining budget process
evaluating your superintendent and then
you know there is a portion that is used
for lobbying we do report to the
secretary of state on a quarterly basis
um i will tell you um
organization wide our lobbying efforts
come in anywhere between about five to
seven percent of our total operating
budget in any given year depending on
the number of bills
that's going to fluctuate this year it's
going to be higher because as i said
there are already 100 bills in house
education that nhsba is is tracking um
so just the the the services are bundled
if you if you will you pay a fee and
you're due to nhsba and you get the
whole kit and caboodle so uh with that
i'm happy to answer any questions that
the committee may have thank you mr
christina questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much
i have no other pink cards uh we're past
our time allotment um so i will close
the hearing on hb 1033
and i will immediately open our hearing
on our 10 o'clock
which is house bill
dealing with extending the public
employees labor relations act to
employees of the general court
and relative to the duties of the joint
committee on legislative facilities
and i will recognize the prime sponsor
oh
that's why uh representative edgar
um
three to four minutes
welcome to legislative administration
thank you very much mr chairman
for the record my name is mike edgar i'm
a representative from hampton
and uh i wanted to thank you mr chairman
and committee members for giving the
opportunity to speak on this bill i'm
here to speak in favor of hp
entitled extending the public employees
labor relations act to employees of the
i did provide a handout it's more of a
summary of
certain things that have happened over
the years
and to basically uh state what this bill
who would cover
the bill establishes a legislature as a
public employer under the public
employee
labor relations act and establishes
procedures for collective bargaining by
nonpartisan employees
the legislature would join the judicial
branch and other state agencies which
already have in place a working program
as public employees under the public
employee labor relations act
this arrangement has worked well
in these other government
entities employees are given the choice
as to whether or not to form a union
basically
existing job action and striking laws
would apply as they do now
to the other groups that already have
had this right
uh
the following is a brief history of some
of the similar past builds i put it in
here because this obviously has been in
front of this this committee met many
times and many of you wherever and many
of you have voted on this before
um
i won't go into a lot of details with
them but basically there were five bills
that i could find before this you go
back any further and the computer
doesn't tell you
give you the information if there are
any it's interested in trying to use
that sometimes
but the
you know starting out in uh
in 1998
there was a hb you know 1405.
um
and then in
then at 18 it was hb
and then
just right here in uh depending on which
teacher used
in in 20 finally there was hb 363.
um
now i think one point of when you lay
these builds out and look at them all at
once
if uh in sb 249
uh the senate passed it
in uh
hb 363
uh the house passed it
now if we just could have got them
together at the same time
we we wouldn't be here discussing this
right now
it would have already passed
but it didn't so that that's why i'm
here
um
and of course this is the bill you know
the
hb 1041 which is which is here now and
why i'm talking
but
almost in summary uh
one of the big things is is to mention
what a non-partisan employee means and
who this would affect it means an
employee whose purpose is to serve
the institution of the general court
rather than to shape or implement
policies that reflect the positions of
elected officials
nonpartisan employees shall include
employees in the following offices and
there's quite a few
the general court administrative office
legislative budget assistant
legislative services
legislative operations
general court technology services
visitors center
protective services
chief operating officer
speaker's house
excuse me speaker's office
house clerk's office
house sergeant-at-arms office
house committee services senate
president's office senate clerk's office
senate research office senate committee
services
senate
administrative assistants
legislative aides
and senate legislative assistants
there's quite a few people i was
surprised when i read through it again
and how long it took to read it
but the
main thing i'd like to say is please
consider giving these non-partisan
employees a chance to choose
and vote this bill otp
thanks for this opportunity to speak to
you and thank you for your testimony i
do have one question if you are
accepting questions oh yes yes sir
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much for your testimony today and for
the history it's very helpful have
any of the employees or departments
listed
on this handout that you gave us
expressed a need or an interest in
forming a union
i would have to say that i haven't done
a comprehensive list especially not
knowing that all these all these groups
actually uh you know the bill would be
against them or affect them i have
talked to a couple people and and they
obviously are interested in this but
um i'm sure that they were like other
things there would be some that
there wouldn't be but that's
the whole thing is to give them the
opportunity to make a choice
thank you
further questions
seeing none and having no further pink
cards um i'll close thank you for your
testimony and i'll close the hearing
we have
here we go
and we have the prime sponsor
ready to go
yes mr chair thank you mr chair and
thank you honorable members for
welcoming me
welcoming me to your committee today
okay oh well just a second i apologize
we're actually not ready
going by
our office oh was it not scheduled for i
thought i was scheduled for 10
um
10 30 by by my calendar
right yeah
just in case people are waiting to turn
on their uh televisions and watch
the hearings at 10 30.
i don't want them to miss a word i'm all
about doing everything properly
and i think i'm joined in the audience
by someone who feels very similar
being our honorable clerk
two two oh i'm sorry i didn't turn this
way
indeed
i'm trying to do 15 things at the same
time
close
i think i'm good i apologize for uh
interrupting you prior
um but i will open the hearing now on
house bill
1083 and welcome
the prime sponsor uh representative reed
welcome to the legislative
administration thank you mr chair and
again thank you honorable members of the
committee for welcoming me
um so i think this is going to be like
the funnest one today because i'm pretty
sure it's the only one where the prime
sponsor is going to say you can i t all
this with my blessing
so the history of this is that right
after i got elected in 2017 i had 30 40
people who wanted to support me and get
active on bills and i had to tell them
you have to go check the website on
thursdays after the house calendar is
available and you have to remember to do
this and if you forget until say sunday
night or monday it might sneak up on you
and you might have a hearing on tuesday
bills that you care about and you know
people have kids and football games and
barbecues or whatever and i felt like it
was really unfair that while we
legislators get emails whenever that
house calendar comes out so we can
immediately go oh yes i need to check i
need to see if my bills are up
the the public doesn't the public you
know can understandably be allowed to
have more of a life outside this this
building than we are so i felt like this
is a very simple uh thing
i uh
i have worked in non-profits and it was
a matter of in the system which is not
the state house system but in the
systems i've worked in at non-profits
it's a five-minute thing to just put up
a subscription field so people can put
their email address in and automatically
receive newsletters you may have seen
this on
dunkin donuts website or you know the
red cross website or you name it very
very easy you don't collect any personal
identifiable information
it's very it's self uh maintained and
that people add themselves and they
unsubscribe themselves extremely easy no
money no manpower required
so
i went to the technical department that
day in 2017 and i said hey can we please
do this it's a really easy thing scott
roop who was the director agreed with me
but he said well it's actually because
the clerk's office i went to the clerk
and they said it was the technical
office and so i kept bouncing back and
forth for about six months until i kind
of got fed up and said i'm not above
legislating this
and that was 2017 so in 2018 i had this
bill
and that bill was before this committee
um and the chair was the honorable dick
hench and out of that hearing it was otp
unanimous on the consent calendar went
over to the senate and in the senate the
senate heard testimony from staff saying
you don't have to legislate this
we're going to do it we're going to do
it on our own
and uh
they didn't so the senate killed it but
they didn't do it and so three years go
by
and now i was uh knowing last year i was
putting in bills in september i started
going to the technical department i said
hey can you just get this done because
this was supposed to be several years
ago this got done
and i was promised it would be done and
they killed the bill because they
promised it would be done and it wasn't
gonna it never was done
and i said if you don't do it i'm gonna
have to put in a bill
so they didn't do it and i put in a bill
having said that we're arriving at the
fun conclusion which is just last week
the honorable clerk brought me into his
office and said look we're doing it and
he showed me and i believe he's here to
show you today
so i would say i'm happy for this not to
be legislated i'm happy for
the the departments that exist to
actually do this correctly and just get
it done
because transparency is really important
and this costs us nothing
having said that i would just simply
request that this committee hold off on
exacting until that is actually up and
uh up on the website and available to
the public but that's all
that's all i have
great thank you uh would you accept
questions
i think you're off the hook i think so
thank you very much for your testimony
i
have no other pink cards but perhaps the
perhaps the
house clerk would like to use his pink
come to the microphone thank you very
much well good morning mr chairman and
honorable members of the best committee
in the new hampshire house of
representatives uh my name for the
record is paul smith i am the clerk of
the house um so just a little bit of
history not to conflict with my
honorable friend uh the member from
newmarket
um
that being said you know obviously
legislation was killed in the past uh
we've had this little pesky thing called
the pandemic for the past almost two
years now that have put a significant
damper on things
one was the rollout of the new website
the the new website was rolled out on
november 1st and many upgrades uh came
along with that including one that i
testified in in behalf of this committee
last year
in legislation dealing with putting
amendments on the website if you go onto
the website now and you look on the
various bill dockets you will see all
amendments that have been offered on
that bill
so again
the there's the question about
legislating policy uh for internal
workings versus um you know legislating
important things like you know education
funding um so i i would just note that
that yes we are rolling things out i
actually do have the subscription
link page
to show you i was going to just walk
around and show you that briefly mr
chairman
if if that is okay with the committee
in it is part of a larger project
it is part of a larger project that has
been ongoing for several years and that
is to create a portal for members of the
public to log in and be able to track
multiple things including legislation
that's important to them so that they
can get text alerts they can get sms
updates etc uh the the point is we do
want
people to be aware of what's happening
here we do want uh people to know what's
going on so they can be involved so this
is part of a of a larger process
to
increase accountability for our members
and accessibility for the public so uh i
do i'll just quickly show you this if
you do yes
are we up and running with that larger
project or is that oh this is it it's
part of a project that's being worked on
now but it has been
it's been certainly a long-term goal of
mine um to have the ability for
for the public to be able to log into
their own portal uh you you know uh for
for all of the members um you know that
we switched to a legislative portal for
members this year uh in terms of
collecting your data for
um the work that we do internally uh and
and we're hoping to utilize some of the
same sort of structure so that people
can get those alerts and and that sort
of thing for legislation upcoming
um rollout date
is it next year or is it i can't tell
you that i'm not a developer i'm i'm
just part of a smattering process now it
is part of the project yes sir
anyone else have
topics of interest um feel free i mean i
i i'm sure i would like to see it i'm
not sure how others feel
that'd be great i think we're all set
actually with that no other pink cards
no other
representative weiler doesn't want to
speak on this bill
so i can close
house bill 1083
with the suggestion that we will hold
yes mr chair
so the time being 10 45 i'm going to
open the hearing on
and represent and recognize the prime
sponsor representative reed thank you mr
chair and thank you honorable members
once again again for the record my name
is ellen reed i represent rockingham 17
new market and new fields
so this is a kind of a transparency and
government bill that
that costs really nothing
and operates much the same way that we
currently operate things like for
example money you know you know gifts
from organizations the only difference
here
is that in essence if a legislator
receives model legislation
from an organization that they simply
have to tell ols that they received it
from this organization and that the name
of that organization would then appear
on the bill
it's kind of the honor system if they
don't do that and someone later on says
hey this bill is exactly identical to
this organization's bill that they're
proposing then it's up to the chair of
that committee to determine whether or
not the bill should have a little line
that says this is from whatever
organization and the chair has 10 days
to make that determination it's as
simple as that
the idea of the bill
and certainly i think and i know i've
put in bills from organizations so this
is not at all like an anti you can't
work with organizations of course we can
organizations do a lot of the heavy
lifting um they can pay lawyers and
obviously i can't pay anyone to do work
for me so that's fine but it's up the
public should know the public should
know
if a particular piece of legislation has
come from an organization or not uh in
this and by the way this was my
predecessor marsha moody's
bill but this has gone through many many
iterations she had kind of like this big
complex
you know confusing thing and this is
just a very very simple disclosure thing
um in this particular version of this i
have
done basically the most conservative by
saying it only applies
to organizations that
interact with elected officials
in more than one state
so if this committee wanted to extend
that to organizations within the state
that only deal with
people in the state then that would be
totally something i would support but
i'm being as conservative as possible by
saying this right now it only applies if
an organization has put out model
legislation and is
interacting or asking legislators from
more than one state to adopt that
legislation
but that's basically it i think i've
explained it and the purpose behind it
and just a transparency thing and i'm
happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony um
i see one question from representative
green
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
where i've come to the understanding of
recently is that
there's a lot of instances where a
legislate a legislator will go to an
organization and discuss an idea for a
bill which results in model legislation
so
i wonder if we're kind of getting into a
chicken versus the egg thing as to
origin i mean is it truly from our
organization or did they get their idea
was the impetus from a legislator who
talked to that organization so what do
we do about this sort of thing thank you
so much for that question because that's
the part that i didn't actually go into
on the on the bill so this is
specifically only if the organization as
an organization has voted to adopt that
model legislation so if i go to
organization and say hey do you have
some information or can i borrow your
lawyer or can i pick your brains for
this information and what what do you
think you would support and they go you
know we would like this language that's
fine that doesn't need any disclosure
but if an organization has officially
adopted yes we support this bill
and then you put in that bill or someone
substantively the same
then you would just simply as a
legislator have to tell ols actually i
got this from
you know america is great you know pac
or whatever you know whatever
organization
so
uh that's it's only limited to again
organizations operate in more than one
state and again if only if they've
officially like the board has officially
voted to adopt that stance on that
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for your testimony and
for your work on this
i'm looking at lines 14 15
and
i see that a written request would be
made to the chairperson of the committee
to where the
which the bill is assigned
then it says the chairperson shall issue
a ruling within 10 business days
it doesn't say that the chairperson will
be working with the committees puts a
burden on the chairperson apparently
all that's
thank you and following that just so
your answer can include both please
decisions of the committee chairperson
may be appealed is this all on the
chairperson
um so
literally all that has to happen for the
chair to make their decision is to look
at the model legislation that the person
says hey it looks just like this
organization's bill
and then the bill and go
yeah they look the same or no they're
too far apart if we put it up to the
entire committee that would require a
meeting of the committee so that would
be far too much i think burden um and
it's easier for a chair at home to just
thank you for taking my question um
a lot of times committee members when
bills are introduced
will ask whether it is model legislation
and how they
how they got the legislation that
they're putting in or the person that is
testifying that's admitting the bill or
coming in later says it's model
legislation from wherever it is
we're i think we're doing that now
but it's actually not put in the bill
and so
you would like to see it put in the bill
right and if it's not put in the bill
then the chairperson has to make a
decision that it should be put in the
bill and an amendment would have to come
forward
an amendment to the bill to add the
model legislation no it's not an
amendment so this is like not part of
the actual bill itself the actual
um part of the bill that changes rsa
stays the same whatever that is but the
front here all of that proceeding
information where it says with the title
who the sponsors the committee and the
analysis what the bill does
that part would just continue to have
one it would have another line that says
associated with what other whatever
organization so it would just be a note
at the header of the bill so there
doesn't need to be an amendment and the
chair only makes a ruling if the sponsor
did not disclose that it was model
legislation and someone from the public
says this looks just like this model
legislation so
there's no penalty for the legislator
it's you know it could have been done
accidentally it could have been whatever
there's no like ethical issue there it's
just simply if a member of the public
says hey this looks exactly like this
organization's bill then the chair can
go yeah let's add that disclosure line
in the heading of the
bill follow up
um
i'm having a hard time understanding why
this is necessary
thank you um because and you're correct
on some bills certainly not all i
wouldn't even say necessarily the
majority but on some bills legislators
do say i'm putting this in for whatever
organization or sometimes they're asked
by a committee member but all of that
information is deep deep within the
committee records so if somebody had the
wherewithal and the time and the energy
to search that and hopefully the issue
was brought up by either the sponsor or
a committee member then they might be
able to find that information by
searching committee records but those
are not as easily found
as the bill itself so having a little
tiny line just a one line saying
this is a
you know this has been disclosed as
being from this organization
is is all it takes much more accessible
to the public and much more uniform
because it's not up to whether or not
the sponsor happened to bring it up or
whether or not a member of the committee
happened to ask them thank you thank you
i thought for sure there was going to be
a follow-up representative expedia
thank you mr chair and thank you i'm
sorry it was a little late to your
testimony i
i i like the a lot of a lot of the ideas
of this so
you know they wouldn't be penal they
wouldn't be penalized and it's more of
awareness for not just us on the
committee but also for the public
um
have you have you see
now i'm asking i was like have you seen
any kinds of bills like this anywhere
else across the country of like where
you know model legislation is is
disclosed
i do know i can't give you exact states
but i do happen to know from the work
that my predecessor in my district
before she passed away and i filled her
seat um the work that she did was based
on other states bills so i do know other
states have worked on this
thank you
representative simon
thank you mr chair
this may be a question out of
youth little legislative ignorance i
don't know
but my understanding is when a
legislator brings a bill forward it's
technically their bill at this point
um what is the importance of disclosing
that it's come from another source if
the bill is good then the bill is good
if the bill is bad excuse me the bill's
bad um and we vote on it according to
its merits from your perspective what is
the importance of knowing where it came
from all of that is correct it is the
legislators bill and technically i guess
it's actually the committee's bill as
soon as it's assigned to a committee um
and it is voted on its merits nothing in
that changes but understanding which
organizations um are influencing that
just
from your perspective why is that
important
i i that seems so obvious to me that i
guess i would say why isn't it i think
that i it as a matter of philosophy i
think that the public has a right to
know pretty much everything that their
legislators do
in terms of legislating
not personal lives but everything they
do in terms of legislating all the work
that we do up here should be 100 percent
transparent
one more
so sorry i'm just trying to understand
it from that perspective
so if i were to bring a bill forward
and
the public thought that it was a good
bill let's say because of course that
would be the case
but then they discovered
that some organization
actually propose this this bill
is the assumption that it might
potentially change somebody's opinion of
the bill because they know where it's
come from and that's why it's important
for them to to know its origin like
once again the the the contents of the
bill is completely public already they
can read the bill and determine on its
merits whether it's good or not um i
just wonder if it's important whether
they know if representative wall brought
it forward because she's maybe of a
different opinion you know in general
than i am
is that going to affect their
decision making or opinion in that
fashion well in general i would say that
if it's a good bill and the public
supports it that in general they
shouldn't care but what if for example a
bill was brought forward that said
and i'm going to fail to reach a
specific example but that said we should
treat certain organizations in this way
and doesn't this make sense because
these organizations over here are doing
this and everybody says well that sounds
right but then you find out that was
actually put in or asked for by an
organization that that would affect
for example so i keep going back to
if
if it's something that the public would
feel anything about then they have a
right to know because they have a right
to know everything that goes on up here
further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you so much
i see no other pink cards on
up
representative you can do that after
this if you'd like
a minute yep you've got it our
chair recognizes
representative weiler thank you mr
chairman representative weiler
rockingham district 13. i have put in
many model bills
and
some of them
i go to i've been a member of alec for
25 plus years
and sometimes you see a bill and
and it's presented before us and it said
here's what they did in ohio
and you look at the bill and say wow
that's a good idea
and i remember one from kansas where
a big law firm put up a lot of money to
get one of their members elected as
attorney general
and then she turned around and she gave
her law firm a contract for the
tobacco settlement
that all they had to do was take some 20
pages change the name
to kansas
and collect 22 million dollars
and wait a minute this doesn't seem
right
so i put in a model bill so that that
would not happen
and quite often when i put in a model
bill there's a certain member of the
other party that always this is an alec
bill
like ooh
you know so
i i don't like that inference because
alec is a very good organization it is
nonpartisan
and the issues that they come up that
when you say it's a model bill
that's the key that this has withstood
court challenges
in maybe three or four states
and so
if
states are similar enough if it's been
challenged in four or five states and
always prevails i guess we shouldn't
have to worry too much about it being
challenged if we pass it in new
hampshire so i think
model builds quite often are a good
thing i don't mind telling it's a model
built and i wouldn't even mind saying if
it came from alec although there are
some people that that's an automatic oh
i'm voting against it so
just my comment here's the pink sheet
thank you
would you accept any questions
i think we have one
if i'm
yeah
i'm gonna wait for you to get back to
and thank you for sitting back down um
so i didn't really get are you opposed
to this bill or are you
in favor of it
i'm opposed that you know it has it has
to be made a big deal out of it
if it's appropriate for the bill to say
yes this has stood the challenges
in five other states
and so i'm bringing the same model that
was originally introduced in such and
um
which brings me to my next question you
said that
court challenges in four to five other
states
court challenges to what whether or not
they have to put that it's model
legislation on legislation or the bill
itself has withstood
challenges the bill i would be
introducing
i'd say this bill was introduced first
in ohio
it was challenged in court
several other states decided to copy it
as a model
and it's been challenged in four other
states
and it's always prevailed
so therefore i'm fairly confident that
introducing it in new hampshire is
somewhat bulletproof
and not not to say
challenge whether or not we have to say
it's a model legislation but if it's
appropriate to the context
then i see no harm in introducing why
it's a model bill and why it has stood
the challenges
but i don't think we need to force
someone to say because
you'll say well i got it from a
colleague in ohio
yes but what is a model a bill from alec
so what
thank you
thank you for the questions
seeing none
you might as well just stay there all
right let me get my
stuff
having seen no further pink cards i will
close the hearing on
[Music]
and
it being 11 o'clock i will open the
hearing on house bill
1102 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative weiler okay i'll wait for
a financial audit
section of the legislative budget
assistant
it is on the state of new hampshire
department of state
so you'll need a copy of the audit and a
copy of my testimony
i think we're set
when you are i'll direct your attention
to the table of contents
on
the page there um lower case i twice
and you'll see
compliance comments significant
deficiencies and compliant compliance
layout to the way the audits come to us
on the fiscal committee
and you'll see number 10 has an asterisk
and number 13 has an asterisk and you go
to the next bottom the next page
where it says audit comment suggests
legislative action may be required
i'm letting the
secretary of state go through number 10
with gel car
but for you and i we have to go to page
21.
where we see
a fairly minor comment
the department has not kept current
certain statutes under purview based on
changing conditions described below
and then it goes commission
rsa 5 colon 13 commission and boards
functioning within department
two of the three entries listed in the
statute the boxing and wrestling
commission and the joint board of
licensure and certification are not
functioning within the department of
state as a separate organizational
entity
but then
the amendment they gave me
when i read it it still has
not
the original bill rather not the
amendment
boxing and wrestling commission number
two boxing arrested commissioner
attachment
um
okay here it is 1102.
attached
which
this section says they're not
so the amendment removes them
uh from
that section of
1102.
and it gives a little more information
boxing and wrestling commission
interestingly enough
when we've
talked to them briefly in
in
budgeting
they don't have a they don't have any
general funds
they exist on filing fees
and my son is a big boxing
fan he'll send me occasional listings
that there's going to be a boxing match
in manchester
there's probably three or four of those
a year
so the the
people that arrange for that have to
um a permit from the boxing and
wrestling commission and make all the
arrangements and of course have the the
proper
agencies that are sponsoring so
they take care of that and then we don't
need to worry much about it but there's
no reason to have them attached to the
secretary of state so
we've cleaned up the language that was
in the original
1102 with this amendment
and
the rest of it
appears to be
accurate especially where we read them
grants review committee
and i read the detail on that i had all
sorts of people that were appointed by
this agency that agency this and so and
so
then it says
the legislature never funded the program
and the grants review committee doesn't
exist
so
why even have it in the law
so that's another reason to remove it
um
along with some of these other things
that
as a result there are no filings and no
fees collected
so why even have them on the books so
this is kind of a nitpicky house pick
house
keeping thing to
to pass 1102 as amended
and
the next time they do a
but a audit of the
department of state they will be happy
that
these have been cleaned up
so
that's my testimony and i'm happy to
answer any questions and if you want to
take some time describe some of this
process
representative um we have a question
from representative roulard thank you
representative roblox
hi thanks for taking my question i'm
the question the the statement begins on
line five the ballot law commission
shall each function
should the word each be removed there
yes
okay
yep we don't need each in there
thank you for catching that
hopefully uh that'll go to the drafting
that's it
um for other questions i have one
so my question is um on the original and
the amendment
um but on the amendment it's line 18
and it talks about rsa 652-24
relative to voter identification
advisory committee
in the lba
report
or how do i
why is that on there i guess is my
question
i understand the boxing and wrestling
why are we repealing the voter
unless when i went to see the drafter
she went back through it and discovered
something else that
maybe she had a conversation with
department of state
but
i didn't know if that was attached to
that when you were saying you were
allowing the
the secretary of state to change some
things through rules i didn't know if
that was part of this or
because there are three repeals shown
and they all three carry forward onto
the amendment
but i'm not sure
i'm not actually sure where the real
would you be able to follow up with the
committee i will do that thank you
um would you
five minutes um
if you would be able to give us a quick
overview of the process perhaps
sorry new information coming from
outside
okay
eliminating the voter identification oh
we're looking at house bill 1269
which is relative to certain legislative
study committees which also eliminates
roman eight absolutely voter
identification advisory board so one way
or the other
it's coming it's going to be eliminated
so maybe that's why the draft to put it
in you want me to follow up or just
um
now that we know where it also exists
who is who's bringing that bill forward
you aren't are they
oh karen
um okay we'll ask that
okay just uh we'll ask at that time
maybe it's just a way of doing it i
don't know why would it be added to this
amendment and not
and that would be rafter might have just
worked on that recently yeah okay
um yes but as far as the audit goes
that's before us
truthfully the only thing that this
pertains to is
um
is the repeal
yes
plus it it takes the boxing and
wrestling commission and the
right we're not actually repealing
that they're just saying they're no
they're not
they're no longer attached to the
secretary of state's office
and where are they are they placed
somewhere else removal of the joint
board of licensure and certification but
where
where did the boxing and wrestling
commission go if they're not attached to
the secretary of state's office rsa 285
okay i i
should have looked at the amendment an
independent commission at that point
okay
it makes our work easier we don't have
to fund them we don't have to
worry about who appoints them or any of
that stuff so
got it anyway to get back to
um we have piles of these
audits
we have
within
um
the legislative
offices there is a legislative budget
assistance
that person works
technically
for the fiscal committee
and the fiscal committee appoints a
legislative budget assistant one person
who then appoints
staff members
there's about eight of them that work
with us on the budget they also work
with public works and ways and means
and
very good accountants
they also have
an audit division which is down the
street
you usually only see them when they come
in and deliver an audit to the fiscal
committee
those on the fiscal committee may decide
well this is worth sending to some other
committee if it's like fish and game
yeah we ought to send it to fish
efficient game let the members of that
committee read all about what they found
in the audit
they do both financial audits and
they do those trying to do those on a
rotating five-year basis
and they also do performance audits and
there is a subcommittee of the
legislature that is a legislative
performance audit oversight committee
and those eight people or so i think
it's four house and four senate
get together occasionally and say
you know we need to do a performance
audit on such and such because
something's come up to say
oh look at all the abuses in
in the department of children and youth
let's do a performance audit over there
and they'll come in and they'll do a
very thorough one they'll look at the
way things are done in other states
they'll look at what the best management
practices are they'll likely publish
them they'll probably put some history
in there and so on and so forth and it's
a very thorough thing and there's a
different group that works on
performance audits and they have mbas
versus cpas
and so
it's uh it's very instructive when you
want to find out something about
a particular function of state
government and it
is always very enlightening when i read
those things and sometimes it
again has little asterisks or sometimes
they have a
they do it in a different format
depending who the auditor is sometimes
you'll see it in a table format and
they'll say legislative needed yes no
you go down that and so
we take that as a guideline on fiscal
committee
what should we put in as legislation so
it became more complicated than i
realized because
someone didn't read it exactly right
we have a question would you take a
question from representative roulard of
course
sometimes it takes me a bit to read it
before i can come up with my questions
your amendment
actually does
keep
the establishment of the commission for
boxing and wrestling under 285
i don't see an end date to that so will
that commission go on
forever
i would assume so
if we don't show an end date and and you
think that that's an appropriate thing
that it should go on forever
as long as people are willing to pay
money to go and watch boxing and
wrestling
we're going to have to have somebody
that's going to certify them and allow
it and
permit it
follow up
so the commission
is actually a certifying
board
yeah
you couldn't just have anybody come in
and say hey i got two guys they want to
start boxing and and uh you know i've
got the
space reserved and i'm selling tickets
and so on so wait a minute
who's the uh
who's the overall
group that's
sanctioning them
is there
a definite group
that will recognize who gets the belt or
the championship or whatever
you don't just have
a boxing club decides to put on a match
you need some sanctioning from some
official body
that this
boxing and wrestling commission we'll
keep track of that
follow-up so that question came from
somebody that doesn't watch boxing or
let's do that
thank you very much for your testimony i
think we're all set okay thank you
um
so i guess we don't need to further them
in we'll just
i think i think we're set the only thing
is that word each but um
we can we can touch that up before we
yes
representative berger pointed out where
it'll be taken care of
later today right
yes
theoretically
thank you all all right thank you
uh with that i will close the hearing on
and move to
house bill 1104
which is relative to the travel
allowance for members of the legislature
i see the prime sponsors isn't here nor
representative hargan you are
oh i'm sorry it is yours i'm sorry i was
looking at a different one on my
on my calendar i apologize uh i do have
a pink card for you
welcome to the legislative
administration thank you very much for
thank you good to be back
so i'm representing timothy horgan i
represent
strafford county district six the towns
of durham and madbury and
my round-trip mileage is 74 miles each
way
this bill is
well it was somewhat duplicated by hb
1650 which we uh
which they fast-tracked was one of the
first things we voted on when we had our
two-day session at the doubletree hotel
i
i asked for this bill drafted uh long
before i knew we'd be meeting in january
at the doubletree hotel although i was
not surprised that we're meeting or
convening somewhere other than the state
the main difference between what i
proposed was first of all i didn't
get into
uh
they also amended a couple of uh
paragraphs that came after the main part
that my bill my bill amended
about uh
submitting
we're officially even though like they
do the computations for us we're
officially supposed to like
the log time implies we're supposed to
calculate ourselves and then submit a
report and then they approve it but um
and then also the verb i used is my
build uses difference i talk about
any other location where the house
senator both bodies in the joint session
are meeting
and then this one says
where
the phrase they use in the same places
as of january 1st 2022
any location where the member bodies
convened and um
i was an english major in college even
i'm not sure the exact difference
between meeting and convening is
although it seems to me
in january 5th through 6th we were
the state legislature was probably still
convened at the state house that was
where the that's where the speaker's
office is and the clerk's office located
we were just meeting
we were just assembling off-site so
whether we're
whether we actually convened in
manchester those two days just you know
you can kind of quibble with that but
either um
probably like uh
either one either phrase serves to uh
first authorize uh what we actually did
which was to pay pay us all for our
mileage from our homes to the doubletree
hotel or in the past unh or the sports
dome
and
um
and uh actually probably there's a
little bit of ambiguity in the law
because certainly having uh committee
hearings off-site is not entirely
unheard of like the budget committee
well they didn't do it this budget cycle
but past budget cycles they've
traditionally had a few uh
meetings at various locations on the
stage and we've always been paying them
the mileage
the committee members and other
other reps who show out the mileage from
where they live to the location not to
conquered and
then one really
nitpicky thing
is that i notice here that if
one legislative chamber is convening or
meeting depending how looking the other
isn't
according to my proposal if a member of
the body that's not convened or not
meeting chooses a drive to the session
day to observe or for whatever other
reason they might want to go they would
still automatically get the mileage
whereas uh
in the proposal hb 1650 which we
actually passed in the law
a couple weeks ago uh
you can only get paid mileage for
going to your
going to see for attending a session of
your own body so like say if a senator
i don't know if any did but i guess my
bill passed like safer meeting you know
it's a sports dome if the senate was a
meeting they could drive down and sit in
that little uh
sit in that little uh balcony or
mezzanine type area over the entrance
and watch us and still get their mileage
and they
probably could have gotten their mileage
anyway but
so that's um
anyway so that that's my bill it's uh
so if you see some value to using my
wording i would be
delighted that i can certainly i can
certainly understand if you don't want
to bother with this at all so um that's
and um
and as also as i said obviously i passed
this long before the decision to meet at
the doubletree was was was made
so thank you thank you very much for
your time thank you um would you be
willing to take questions sure kevin
one oh i'm in trouble
i guess it's my day today
um
i just had a question um on lines 15 and
it appears as though a representative
that is
traveling for 45 miles gets a certain
percentage per mile
and for all miles in excess of that 45
miles they get 19. i know that's current
law but was that looked at when you were
doing this
well looked at a little bit that's a
um the origins of
the origin of that go way back about 60
years when
there was some couple of court cases
about mileage before that i think we
could just set our own mileage and
anything we wanted and uh
the payments i think were medications
much higher than they are now but um
this is something called the uh
this is something called the federal
plan which only a handful of members
still sign up for because um
it's less attractive in most cases
because it's taxable income but some do
choose to sign up for it for uh
reasons of their own like for example i
think some signed up for it in order to
get credit towards social security so
that's i mean that's something maybe
should be looked at at some point but
that's kind of a relic
from several decades ago and has stayed
in the law and um maybe some merit to
eliminating that or changing changing
the rate to the current rate but i was
just taking something that's been
sitting in the law books for really for
decades
one last follow-up and the reason i
asked that is on line 19 it talks about
if we paid at the maximum rate
established by the internal revenue code
so i just wondered if there was a
conflict there and whether or not lines
15 and 16 should have been removed from
the statute
uh
i i don't know you're you're very good
i'm not a lawyer you're a very you're a
lawyer and a very good one from what i
stand and um i don't don't really don't
really have a uh don't really have an
answer off the top of my head head for
that um that's all this is also a
language that's been in there for a long
time we're just
both cases the aim of both this bill and
the other one was just to add this uh
it's just authorized ourselves to pay us
for off-site uh sessions all right thank
you very
much further questions
um
i have one
if you don't mind um so my my question
is
everything that this bill of yours does
is currently being done by um a simple
vote
taken at the beginning of session
um when we were not in the emergency but
everyone um
suspended the rules in order to make
sure that we were all paid is that is
that essentially correct that we are
just
um this this bypasses the suspension of
the rules um necessitated
to pay from a separate location
all right kind of as i understood the
separate the suspension rule this is
actually bill so it's been permanently
on those uh rsa 1415a and
one two they've been permanently changed
by the bill so it wasn't just a one-time
resolution to for that one week but that
was
a bill which
was introduced in the rules committee
and they gave themselves permission to
uh you know drafted suspend the
deadlines and then the full house gave
them permission to draft the deadlines
and we sent it to the senate and they
passed it so that's uh yep thank you
very much it's been permanently changed
so yes thanks appreciate it
um
we were getting a
nod that the uh honorable house clerk
would like to
comment briefly on this
and help us with very briefly mr
chairman again paul smith clerk of the
house uh thank you for
recognizing me um
so just just a quick clarification
uh there's nothing and again i testify
neither in support of nor in opposition
to legislation um the situation
regarding representative horgan's bill
and the reason why new legislation was
filed
for the emergency purposes we have to go
back to the pandemic
during the pandemic when we were meeting
off-site and we were under the state of
emergency the governor issued an
executive order which allowed for the
legislature to be paid in an off-site
manner
that was part of one of the executive
orders that was
issued and that's how we were able to
pay you while we were meeting at the
whitmore center at
the field hockey pitch outside the
woodwork center at the parking lot and
then at the sports plex
the situation is that
we had to fix something
on the fly
in order to make
the doubletree work
and we had to do it in a manner that was
specific to that and that was why
legislation was filed that wasn't there
was there was nothing against
representative horrigan's bill nobody
was against the concept it was specific
to
needing to carve out that exemption for
the doubletree for those first convening
days of 2022 sessions so that was the
whole purpose
in that emergency
you know suspension of the rules and
getting things done but it was but uh
the doubletree was not
we were out of the the emergency period
that's correct
that's correct and that is why we needed
legislation because uh without that
legislation and
and and unfortunately representative
horgan's bill didn't address
that meeting off site at that point what
it didn't have that immediate effect um
and so that was why uh it was
literally rushed through and we it was
signed into law the very day that we
passed it which is
extremely unusual as as most of you know
um
that being said uh representative yard
asked questions about the mileage i
would just note that we have two mileage
rates we have a federal rate and a state
rate the federal rate is
what the irs computes the state rate is
a different
effect and that's why you see different
references within the statute
so i would just
that that's sort of the the background
on that
great um further questions
yes
i knew there would be one yes he knew it
the question wasn't quite so much that
the state versus the federal rate it's
for the first 45 miles you get a certain
amount and for all miles after that you
get another
i i think if representative i think if
you want to study that issue that would
be a perfect example of
of utilizing the ad hoc committee
process for
for an in-depth study
on why it is we do the things we do was
that a volunteer
so follow up on this question
the question is then a statement perhaps
it's not good for them i i would i would
note that it depends on the mileage rate
that you're taking
because if you're taking one mileage
versus a different one you are you are
going to be compensated differently but
you also have to remember too that
somebody potentially driving from
pittsburgh uh may likely be staying over
and isn't entitled to the federal
mileagery
because they stay over
and and you have to take you have to
swear an affidavit every time you come
down that you've traveled that full
mileage so correct
thank you of course anytime
i think we're set
great thank you
thank you honorable clerk
um
having
we have we will close that hearing
and it being past the time of 11 30 we
will open
the hearing on 11 29.
a pink card uh not from the prime
sponsor but from representative expedia
yes that will be yeah can you hold on
just a minute please while we reset and
uh
and get things in order and we'll be
with you in a second
yeah
that was
yes
good
welcome
to your committee representative
great to be here so um apologize that
representative cushing couldn't be here
but um i am
uh as one of the co-sponsors happy to
introduce hp 1129 relative to the fiscal
committee of the general court so this
bill was filed by representative cushing
to ensure proportional partisan
representation on the joint fiscal
committee
the fiscal committee is one of the many
statutory committees established in
title one of new hampshire's rsas most
statutory committees contain
requirements in the law for minority
party participation or representation
sorry so for instance
joint facilities committee
requires a minority leader or doesn't
need to be appointed the joint
legislative historical committee
requires minority leader or designee to
be appointed
and the long-range planning commission
appoints four house members no more than
three from any political party
the fiscal committee differs
from these in that it contains no
requirement for minority party
appointment
under the current statutory construction
the fiscal committee consists of the
finance chair two members appointed by
the finance chair and two members
appointed by the speaker
this means that under current law there
is no guarantee of minority party
representation on the fiscal committee
the speaker and finance chair are
allowed to appoint an unproportional
membership even zero members of the
minority party to the fiscal committee
if they desire
this term even though the house
membership between two parties is even
more
than ever before
the speaker chose to appoint four
members of the majority party and only
one member of the minority party to
fiscal
this bill will align
the fiscal committee statute with other
statutes establishing statutory
committees which require minority party
representation
though the method outlined in the bill
the fiscal committee will be three
members for the majority party at 60
percent and two members 40 for the
minority party and this aligns with the
common common practice that most
speakers appoint three majority members
and two minority members and with voter
sentiment
and um
i would also make it so that the
the person chosen would be done by the
minority leader rather than uh the
speaker um so you know just some other
ideas to consider it i mean the prime
sponsor is open to any amendments on it
but
um was open to the idea of amendments
but you know you can change the language
in-house rules on standing committee
representation requiring that fiscal
committee membership
uh be divided into two major political
parties in the same proportion
uh as the house membership of the
majority party and
the house membership of the minority
party um or you can change it to like i
said the commission the long range
planning commission of no more than
three members of the same party of the
four members that it requires so
with that um you know i'm open to taking
any questions and uh conclude my
testimony
thank you for your testimony um i do
have a question understand that this is
not
the representative's
bill you understand that so
okay fine pretty cool respond i didn't
want you to be um saddled with technical
questions when
you didn't put it together well it might
actually be a question that the clerk
can answer better to be honest but uh
this bill pertains to
uh what the senate can do and cannot do
are we authorized to
ask away
i mean this bill is also going before
the senate so they they'll have a chance
to to also make any changes if they
believe that they want to make any
changes to their their side of it so it
will go to both committees yeah both
sides okay yeah i was just curious
because where we would actually be
voting on what they are can and cannot
do so i just wasn't sure if that was
appropriate or not that was all right
and they would vote on what we
what we could do and what we can't do as
well as if it went over to their side
if it did pass the house once again
first year i'm just
asking questions that i don't know
answers to it helps me too so don't
worry
okay thanks think we're all set no
further questions thank you
i do have another pink card however from
a
long time
fiscal committee
stan stalwart
representative ken weiler
would like to speak on house bill 1129
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
as you say i've been on
i think i've been on fiscal committee
longer than anyone else at this point
um
when i was
first on it and
first cheering it in i think 2012
and
and i went and saw the speaker and said
okay i get two appointments and you get
two appointments
traditionally we've had
uh three members of the majority party
and two members of the minority party
and he says well i'm appointing this
person and this person i said you're not
appointing a democrat
he said no you want any democrats on it
you've got to appoint them so i
appointed to democrats but we
traditionally stuck with that
most of the time before i was on the
fiscal committee when rep
representative scitec was the speaker
i remember at one point she decided that
she needed more control on this on the
fiscal committee
and so she put on
her two appointments one of them was i
think the majority leader and the other
one was
the chairman of ways and means
and
speaking with those people i was on the
finance committee at the time but not on
the fiscal committee speaking with those
people later they said
i don't know what i'm doing here
basically all the issues that come
before fiscal committee are budgetary
also those
things i just pointed out with all of
the reports that we get from
the lba
audit division
we read audits we accept grants we
approve transfers from this
line to that line very much budget
related
so what's happening to this budget that
we're putting the money from here to
there and also keeps it in mind for the
next time we do the budget why did you
have to move so much money from here to
there tell me what happened
whatever it's a it's an insight into
what's happening in the next budget or
in the present budget
so
all the stuff is budgetary
so at one point
uh
the
[Music]
house
had a majority democrats and the senate
head majority republicans
the senate appointed
one democrat
and four republicans
so the house said oh
you're not going to get away with that
we'll appoint four democrats
and one republican which was me
because i was the only one willing to be
the clerk
nobody else wanted the job
i think that had more to do with it
than
than my actual party
and i had been the clerk a few terms
before that so
um yes so it ended up with four and one
and then uh
after that
the presence
well
dick hinch said
okay we only need one democrat on
they've done that to us in the past
where we only had one republican so we
don't need more than one
and okay that was his appointment so
that's
that's the way it's been now for
a year or more
so
but
when we take this thing and make the
minority leader be the appointee i'm
fearful that it's going to be the
minority leader and and maybe somebody
else that
as i
experienced in the past when
speaker scitec did this these people say
i don't know what i'm doing here
because the issues that came before you
wait a minute i don't i didn't look at
that budget i don't know what happened
there i don't know whether this is a
good transfer a bad transfer i don't
know whether it's worthy or not uh and
i've never read audits before and so on
and so forth and
and i think they tried to get off of it
the people that had been appointed who
were not members of the finance
committee either of the house or the
senate
very important that you have that budget
experience when you sit on the fiscal
committee because
by law the fiscal committee
is a
creation of the house and the senate
to take care of issues when the house
and senate are not in session
these are bills that would normally come
before those two committees
so
since those two committees are not in
session like in
june july august september and so on
fiscal committee will still meet
and so somebody wants to accept a grant
they can't spend that money
unless
the legislature appropriates it
so
the fiscal committee serves as the
appropriating body by the law that sets
them up
so it kind of gives it a little bit of
leeway over what would normally be the
case
money can't be spent unless it's
appropriated
the appropriating body is the
legislature so
we are kind of the designees for that
particular those particular months and
even some of the intervening months so
i i don't want to get
it to become too political
and i i see the bill as doing that
and i think it will
maybe
make it more difficult for the committee
to function if they don't have
all 10 people familiar with the budget
so
that's why i oppose the bill thank you
thank you for any questions
you may guess that there is one question
at this at least i always appreciate it
that is inquiring minds wanted
representative roulard thank you for
taking my question of course um
i i appreciate your testimony because
when i was reading this i was thinking
the same thing we need to have people
that
know what finance is all about and what
we're dealing with
but also thinking that at some point the
party that i'm in now maybe the minority
party at one point
um which is a way i have a tendency to
look at things
so
wouldn't it be
fair to have the chairperson of finance
a point because the them they're on it
already appoint two members of minority
and two members of a majority
and they have the senate do the same
thing
i think you take away some of the
flexibility there might be people you're
familiar with all the people and if
you're the chairman of financial they're
familiar with all the people there and
some
some are in deep thought some are
filling a seat and you say okay uh
you know
who's who's gonna function best on this
or
there might be people that have poor
attendance
at even your regular committee why would
why would i want to put that person
there when i'm always having to fill in
for them and they're not and they're not
reading the material they're not keeping
up because there's sometimes there's a
pile of stuff like this
that you have to read you get it a week
in advance
so you're familiar with who really gets
into the material and who just kind of
says yeah okay i got it here somewhere
i can't find it you know so
i'm looking at people that really do the
job rather than
and and i would appoint democrats that i
knew
did a study
and
were right up on the on the budget and
had had been working hard and had had
that way of
keeping up with
not only the budget but the changes to
it and the reasons why we do what we do
and
i'd always appreciate experience that
had people that had been on the fiscal
committee with before
and had seen them operate
but if you just kind of make it you've
got a point two minority two majority
i think it it
takes away some flexibility from the
person who want to know
of the 20 people i'm looking at
which ones are going to work thank you
thank you uh question representative
simon thank you mr chair um in that same
vein would it make more sense than to
have the committee chair choose two
people and the ranking member choose two
people that way the person of the
minority party would be well acquainted
with everything that's going on and able
again it comes down to sometimes the
ranking member
is not the the busiest person on the
committee they're not
they're there because they're they've
been there longer than anybody else and
they're kind of losing it
but hey there's nobody senior to me i i
deserve it
and like i say i'm i'm i would be
looking for people that i know would
go through that in a week
and
be ready to ask questions and be ready
to to
contribute in a thoughtful way of what
we ought to do with this so
it i think it it's worked fine the way
it is
uh
next time i would try to go back to
three and two again
but you know that was kind of okay they
did that the last time we'll do it this
uh i don't want to get into that
but
i know that there's
there's
two members of the minority party that i
would in an instance say yes those
people do the work they do the study
let's have them on there because
it's not always partisan
there's lots of things that you have to
figure out
why do we want this grant what's the
effect of it
and you know like
the hassle i got into because
it was this money
i i thought everybody that wanted a shot
could get one
and all of a sudden were offered two
different grants the total 27 million
but we got to hire 15 more people
and
one of the things that i didn't want to
give up the sovereignty of the state
said
you will comply with all federal health
and human stat health and human services
rules
that are present now or in the future
and also you will have
state
enforcement people
cooperate with federal agents who might
want to isolate people or quarantine
people wait a minute
if if the federal government says to us
we're going to go out and arrest
everybody that hasn't had the shot and
put him in a camp
like australia
that's not something live free or die
state would ever put up with
but
if you took this money you're more or
less
saying you're going to help them
and
i said no i don't think we should give
up our sovereignty and most of the
committee agreed with that so
there are things that you have to read
the fine print of what goes along with
you know like sometimes it was like okay
if you take this highway money then we
will tell you what the speed limit will
be
do we want to give that over to the feds
i don't know
we've done it but
you know there is something
nothing comes without strings
so
you have to do the study and see what's
going to happen if we take this grant
and and if if the committee members have
not done the study because there might
be 100 items
and
you don't want to overlook anything
important like that so
i
try to rule with people that i know will
do this study thank you
thank you
no further questions i think we're all
set thank you very much representative
weiler
thank you
with that i will close the hearing on
11 29
and
i don't
know if we have anyone to introduce
so do we take an early lunch
and hope that they show up after lunch
that would be the courteous thing to do
would it not
are you um no one is here for 11 54
other
okay
um why don't we have representative
simon can you just introduce 11 54 and
then we can hear from our clerk who we
yeah but why don't you introduce it then
we can hear from the clerk and meanwhile
you can call him and see if you can
get him over here
and then we'll be done with our whole
morning
session thank you mr chair thank you um
i would like to introduce uh hp please
tell us who you are oh sorry uh
representative matt simon grafton 14 i
reside in littleton new hampshire thank
you
um i would like to introduce hp
1154 relative to legislative commission
inactivity
it is a bill that establishes a
committee to study legislative
commission inactivity
thank you very much
that's my testimony
no questions
thank you
um i would like a pink card from you and
if you could grab a oh we can do a pink
card but we'll bring it over um
paul uh smith um our house clerk would
you like to chime in on 11 54. uh
thank you mr chairman uh pleasure to be
back in front of you for the third time
today
uh not the last sorry to say um so just
just very quickly um no problem uh again
paul smith house clerk uh not testifying
in support or opposition i just wanted
to point a couple of quick things out
one
um
the focus of this uh this particular
piece of legislation is also addressed
in upcoming legislation but this is much
more restrictive and i would only note
that
um some of the language of this
we have to keep in mind that the
pandemic is going on and has been going
on for the last two years and some of
our committees and commissions that have
been historically active in the past
and i see representative barry coming in
some of our his some of our commissions
and committees that have been very
active historically because of the
pandemic have not been as
uh active in this past year and a half
and i would just note that a look back
of only one year um
in in measuring the multitude of
committees and commissions we have may
be a little bit on the short-sighted
aspect and that's why um again the the
this this subject matter is addressed a
little bit later in house bill 1269
which i think
does do a little bit further of a look
back and actually puts a time limit on
on committees and commissions as well
which i think is a very good thing so i
just wanted to throw that in there for
consideration thank you
oh look we have the prime sponsor i'm
sorry about that i'm in hearing and i
just introduced another bill so
apparently uh and i'm double dipping for
sweeney who decided to show up to what
today goes unpunished yeah i know
welcome to legislative administration
representative barry please uh
introduce yourself and uh and talk about
your bill please i am the uh the
apologize for my lateness representative
barry um
i uh my bill is trying to adjust address
legis uh inactive committees and
legislative committees um
um but the bill is not ready for prime
time unfortunately i ran out of time to
really get to where i needed to go
it's a vehicle that's obviously
available for the committee should you
use it my intent in filing it
was we have if you ever look at the the
house calendar that the wonderful clerk
cover puts together we have umpteen
billion um study committees and this
committee and that committee um a lot of
them don't even meet anymore the
speaker's office then has to fill these
commissions
so it was not a
there was a
admittedly an issue
when when i thought of the idea that i
didn't fully think it out of which is i
wanted to be forward-looking but you
can't make legislation that's
forward-looking on other legislation on
other future committees so um when i
when i realized i had done that horrible
uh
assault on the constitution if you will
and i went oh well this is uh this idea
will needs more thinking i said i ran
out of time so the the vehicle exists
that was my intent um but um anybody who
speaks after me is probably wasting
their time because if this goes on the
consent calendar to die
thank you for your testimony um would
you be interested in taking any
questions hey please ask me about
questions about the bill that i don't
anyone have anything and i apologize to
the poor person from all of us who had
to write this
thank you very much for your i'll take
that pink card if you don't mind and i
think we're
darn close to on time um we'll
we will close the hearing
on 11 54
and we will
skip it all the time
yep
testing
so the time being one o'clock
um
we start on our
afternoon odyssey here
um
one o'clock we have scheduled house bill
1170 which is limiting the authority of
new hampshire delegates to policy-making
conventions
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
uh representative scott wallace
speaking in favor of the bill obviously
representative wallace welcome
to your own committee
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record uh my name is
representative scott wallace i represent
the town of danville rockingham county
district 12.
i'm introducing house bill 1170
this bill would establish procedure for
the selection of delegates to
article 5 and interstate conventions
policy making conventions that is
absent this particular bill there are no
methods of disciplining or reining in a
rogue delegate um
at one of these conventions um
historically we found that
we seem to be reluctant to move forward
with any of these conventions absent
ground rules for the delegates
this particular bill is
not quite verbatim but very close to
house bill 148 that passed both the
house and the senate back in 2015
it was actually on the consent calendar
on the house floor
was pulled off consent by representative
horrigan but subsequently passed with a
a
233-76 vote again passed the senate on a
voice vote consent calendar and was
subsequently vetoed by the governor at
that point in time
and is we're getting closer to an
article 5 call nationally
presently there are approximately 27 or
states that have a concurrent resolution
for proposing a
balanced budget amendment to the u.s
constitution
uh there are at least four or five
states pending presently so
if those states would have these
concurrent resolutions passed this year
um the convention would be called and we
would need to have these ground rules in
place for the delegates that we select
to represent our interest at the
national convention
um
that being said it's pretty
straightforward uh again it
was debated quite extensively uh
six or seven years ago and uh
made it through the house and senate but
was vetoed by the governor so that's
where at this point in time i'd be more
than happy to take any questions thank
you um one
one quick request by the chair um
would it be possible for you to provide
to the committee the veto message um
that came from house bill 148
i will get that
and share that with the committee as
soon as i can right after appreciate it
that would be great um are there
questions
anyone
seeing none you're free to go
um
chair recognizes uh
a second speaker speaking in support of
the bill uh representative jordan uhlery
um
hillsboro 37 five minutes
thank you mr chair for the record my
name is jordan hullery hillsborough 37
hudson and pelham
interestingly enough new hampshire has
already attended a convention of the
states
this was the phoenix
meeting
several years ago and where rules for an
article 5 convention were
devised
both the speaker and the president of
the house at the time selected
individuals to go i was one of the
individuals selected to go
it was interesting
130 degrees in the shade
because they did it in august dry heat
it was warm
the
per the need for this is as was
indicated there are some 28 states that
have got a complete package done under
the balanced budget amendment
there are another five or so
states that are
considering
a balanced budget amendment and there's
a couple that have
substantially the same language but
inclusive of some other language
under the what they call the convention
of states language
it depends upon
the congress but they could accept those
as well and the convention would be
called
then we're
ready to go
and once we're ready to go we don't have
to wait for the other states to get
their act together we can go down there
and say
we're here where are you
and puts you know from a little bit of a
pride position
we can set up and say we're ready to go
it also serves as a guide for other
states although i believe indiana has
this similar type of legislation already
in place
but what it does is it just makes it
easier
and we can just go forward from here
with it
so that uh
indicate that somebody's afraid of a
runaway convention
not in new hampshire we've got rules in
place to say if you don't fall if you
don't vote only on this
material
come home we don't want you there
so
that's why it's there and i'll be happy
to answer any questions regarding that
thank you for your testimony i will
check to see if there are any questions
there is one representative roulade
i just did that so i didn't have to ask
my friend scott questions but i think
you know the answers as well i'm looking
at page one and page two of uh house
bill 1170 specifically on page one
lines 25 through 31
and on page two lines one through six
and it talks about how folks are
appointed
by the new hampshire senate
is
and the questions that i have is that is
that appointment done
by majority vote or by an individual in
the senate
i don't know
then you probably also don't know how
they are appointed from the house
i know how they were appointed from the
house in the senate in the previous
event that's not the question i know
so the process by which we have in place
here
at the very premise on how folks are
appointed seems to have something that
needs clarification
it may very well and i would recommend
that that be either by appointment uh
by the speaker
slice president
or it would be by a majority vote of the
body
so is there somebody going to be doing
an amendment on that section of this
bill for us do you know
yes i do know
and the answer would be yes
he would be here
thank you
thank you uh before you go um i also
have a question is this um
identical or substantially the same or
do you know
um
to house bill 148 that was passed prior
yes
it's substantially the same it is not
verbatim okay
99 and 44 100 identical would you would
you be able to provide
the differences um
if you're going to tell us that this
passed in 2015
i want to know what what past versus
what we have in front of us now
thank you in reviewing that it appears
to be mostly linguistics and the
inclusion of some
better
language in its definitions the new
hampshire is already a member of several
interstate
entities
and conventions including several
compacts most notably the connecticut
valley compact
and the uniform law commission
and yes that's the other one
so my other question
and i have to confess i heard this on a
late night radio program one
time going along
did you see any no no no
did um
is is why
could this be done on an ad hoc basis i
think you almost touched on that a
little bit and just said that you know
we could just show up
but
but is there any is that possible in
your in your understanding and and is
that
something that
would be seriously considered
when i spoke to the uh regarding the
phoenix assembly meeting
uh
if you remember we were appointed
by the speaker by and the senate was
appointed by the senate upon receipt of
a request from
the legislature of arizona to establish
such an event
um the then speaker of the house in
arizona is now a member of congress
um
but that i think when
some 32 states responded affirmatively
and then a hurricane hit
for new hampshire to send delegates to
that
it was a little sketchy there were no
rules we were told to do the best we
could
and
there was no guidance as to what we
could or couldn't do
by
this legislation
you get who's going to be appointed
and as was pointed out by representing
the roulard how they're going to be
appointed thank you ma'am
uh
and what they can and cannot do and what
happens when they screw up
so
it just gives a little more guidance to
whomsoever is appointed as a delegate
thank you
anyone
no
thank you
as long as we are looking at things and
cleaning things up on page two of this
bill
it talks about the expenses of the
delegates that we send to the convention
and we're paying them the same per diem
rate as received by members of the
general court what would that be
that would be there's no per diem right
received by the members of the general
court there is no per diem rate right so
that sentence then should be um taken
so how follow up
yes so how will the delegates get paid
then
they would be uh provided room and board
so there's going to be something like
that follow up and an amendment that's
and one follow one more question
if we go down to on page two and we talk
about on line 17 it says the delegates
from new hampshire to an interstate uh
convention shall not have the authority
to allow considerations for approved of
an unauthorized amendment how is that
defined
that would be something
exactly as using common
law if it's not authorized
for their purpose of their appointment
by their commission
then it would be unauthorized so if
they're appointed to a balanced budget
amendment
convention
they couldn't talk about
um
green
energy policy as an amendment to the
constitution
follow up follow-up so when they're
talking about
um
authorized balanced budget if there is
an amendment that's not been authorized
by whomever it is
um on the balanced budget would that be
considered then an authorized amendment
what
yeah
okay no one can understand me i'm trying
to hone in on what you said about if
it's an amendment on some other subject
if it's an amendment on the subject that
they're voting on
is that considered an authorized
amendment yes if it's okay if for a case
in point
individuals are sent down for a balanced
budget amendment convention
the only topic they're going to talk
about is a balanced budget amendment
substantially to the language of their
application or their petition
to
congress for
such a convention
so that they're limited to that
information
okay and nothing else
follow up and i'm assuming that that's
going to be something that's put in the
amendment as well so we can define that
in some fashion that i think is already
in there pretty well because it's well
it's not you're not reading it but
okay thank you i did thank you
further
so my quick question as a follow-up on
that is
at one point we heard from the prime
sponsor saying that there was no
restriction on a runaway quote-unquote
convention
but it would seem to me
that this would prohibit
new hampshire from
considering or supporting or approving
anything that would
be
considered as a runaway is that right
that's correct and let me go back to the
uh original
convention call to revise the articles
of confederation
new hampshire delegates were sent down
there
they got down there and realized that
they were talking about not revising the
articles of confederation
but establishing an entirely new system
of government they came home
then they went back down with the
approval of the legislature
full authority
to do whatever was necessary to create
a new form of government because the
article you know it was just that a new
president every six months that he's
you know if you know your history you
know it worked about as well as dropping
a rock and water and hoping that it
would float
um
you know so that's
okay
i think i'm set anyone else nope we're
good to go thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
uh anyone else would like to speak on
1170 i don't have any other pink cards
and i think we're good i will close the
hearing on 1170
and i think we have
four minutes or so before we start up
with uh
12.69
uh
hello
welcome to
the 1
hearing on house bill 1269.
[Music]
the chair recognizes
the prime sponsor
representative ebel speaking in support
for
five to seven minutes
welcome to legislative administration
again again well thank you very much for
having me um it's good to be here um
for the record my name is karen ebel and
i'm here to introduce hb 1269
a bill that would
repeal or amend certain
statutory commissions and also
include the creation of a review
committee and many other things that i
will describe
so
as you know since you've heard this tale
several times
when i first became deputy speaker i was
pretty shocked to find out that
approximately 300 appointments had to be
made to approximately 240
statutory commissions in fairly short
order and it was quite amazing to me
that we had as many commissions as we
did
it had been 10 years since neil kirk and
lori harding had done a complete review
of all the existing statutory
commissions
and we determined at that time that it
was high time to do another review of
them
so what we did
over the course of two years we did a
complete um
cataloging of all the existing
commissions we figured out and i worked
with pam smarling of house committee
services she looked at you know when
they had met and all that sort of thing
and then we created a procedure where
we reviewed every single commission um
with the
age the administrative agency that it
was attached to to assess its further
usefulness
the other thing we did is we went
through every single
executive order from the governor and
looked at every commission that was
created pursuant to those orders and we
made recommendations on that basis and
that resulted in a series of
bills to
basically embody the bipartisan
recommendation of the
committee on committees
so what you have
here today is hb 1269 hb 1269
is
important in part
identical to the bill that you folks saw
and passed through um hb 186
last term
and as you know it failed in the
committee of conference so i'm i'm back
here and that and so you see the first
part of the of the bill does have the
i had been in conversations with speaker
packard's office who had similar
concerns
to speaker shirtless about the
proliferation of these commissions and
he really wanted to
work
toward
putting some procedures into place to
see if we couldn't winnow them and also
put in sort of a re routine review
process
and representative um umberger was also
tasked by the speaker to work with me in
development of um some of these concepts
so
um
just jumping ahead to that section of it
[Music]
the other thing in working with house
counsel jim cianci
we realized that there really wasn't a
distinction in statute made between
legislative study committees that are
only
members of the legislature and those are
set forth in chapter law and codified
statutory committees which is what we
around here call them which includes not
only
legislative members but members of the
public lobby you know lobbyists
representatives of different
organizations
so what we tried to do here
is very clearly distinguished between
the two of them
now um when i mentioned originally about
having to make 300 appointments to
approximately 240 statutory commission
they are statutory commissions those
aren't the member only chapter law
committees
so
um one of the recommendations of the
committee on committees was that
there be a routine review of these
commissions so you didn't wake up one
day after 10 years and realize that you
know the roof was caving in because we
had so many and working with
representative umberger who had
experience on the joint committee on
dedicated funds
we put together
a committee that would review
the existing statutory committees on a
revolving basis
and
i feel
that by putting this sort i mean i've
talked to some people they they think
it's sort of counterintuitive to create
a committee to review committees but i
sincerely believe that unless we have
some sort of routine in place to review
these things way goes on to way
and they will just continue to
proliferate
in fact i was driving down here this
morning and i was thinking okay this is
like a lawn and if you ignore it you
know the grass just keeps growing and
growing and growing and pretty soon you
have a
forest and then it's really a whole lot
of work to cut it back down to uh lawn
again so i think we really have to work
on that the other thing that um
that was recommended by our committee on
committees was that you build in a
repeal date by law for every single
statutory commission that is passed and
what we have in here is five years so
that it will be clear that these things
have to repeal at a minimum
or at a maximum after five years and if
they want to continue then somebody's
got to introduce a bill to have them
continue and then the other thing that
we all really felt strongly about is
that you had to cap the number of
members because some of these things can
have 20 30 40 members and it creates an
unbelievable burden on the
administrative
and legislative staff
to try to
manage that sort of thing so we capped
it at 15.
the other thing that we did in here is
we put in in the law
that the reports from these statutory
commissions which we're calling codified
study committees in here have to be sent
to the standing committees with the
jurisdiction over the subject matter
that the study committees have because
the other thing that i found is that
although it was nice that all these
reports were going to the clerk and to
the senate president and the house
speaker in many cases they weren't going
to the committees that really should be
up to speed on what these things were
studying
so we have that in there and we also
have in here that
we want to make sure that the study
committee
the codified study committee reports go
on the general court website so they're
and i think that's just about it uh
and i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you very much thank you for your
testimony um
um i have one okay
just to warm it up um my
i'm i'm reading your testimony and um in
the last four
words on the first page were
but with some additions
um i'm wondering
if you can
quickly in
tell me
everything that you've just testified is
that considered those some additions yes
sorry if that was unclear in the
testimony no i'm just clarifying yeah
that's it
so um
you've added these features that you've
talked about
for which we've taken notes
um
under the the
under the old
um
statute i guess for that that created
your organization right
so how does your organization go away
it's gone it doesn't exist anymore so
november was the last
filing right the final filing that's
correct okay it was automatically
repealed
okay
um
we had some
concern and i and it may be that
representative umberger can explain it
to us
from a prior bill that we had today that
had
two or three
extra repeals added to it
that comes from this bill i believe
i i'm i'm not sure i'm aware of that
bill and and thank i i thank
representative umberger for making me
aware of it
i think it was the bill that was
introduced by representative weiler
there were three
commissions on there were three things
on there i double checked them two of
them are in my bill
but one of them i think um
and and she can talk more to this but i
think one of them um you know time
marches on we did our review a year and
a half or so ago this one apparently has
also been recommended for repeal that's
in that other i mean at the time we
didn't but that doesn't mean it isn't
deserving to be repealed
um
thank you for your response i i also
recall and i had in my notes from the
prior years that we looked at this
that there were issues with weights and
measures that we dealt with um or and
i'm and i'm not sure
the disposition of that problem and we
also had an issue with um
a membership of a seacoast organization
so what i what i did uh representative
hill is that i went ahead and i used for
this bill the version of the bill as it
was passed in the senate
and the senate actually removed the
section
on fish and game for the reasons that we
discussed during our you know the
hearing when i was here before um
uh
they got testimony and they decided at
that point that it was advisable to
remove it from from our version of the
bill and then um the other thing was
that i remember um
commissioner uh jasper had communicated
that he wanted to get rid of the weights
and measures and they included that in
the senate version of the bill
okay so that part was taken care of yeah
the last part that i recall was
something through the department of
insurance
that they had a
um
a repeal
or they no they um
objected to something that was being
repealed they thought was
incorrect does that i'm i'm not
remembering that but all the arguments
that um
that were made i
sent senator carson and her committee
basically took care of and that's why i
thought it made a lot of sense to just
start with the bill the way it was
passed by the senate and use that as our
model
okay
i'm done anyone
no
thanks for coming i it's not that i have
an additional question it's really to
kind of
have my notes that i have i think from
the last hearing we had as well
and i think that there was
something to do with insurance oversight
and
that was in there ten years ago
i think that must be what you were
talking about with the insurance
department
and there was also some joint health
care
issues that were repealed as well so
that's no longer in this bill that we
have in front of us
i'm sorry i just i don't i'm not
remembering the department of insurance
section though the one that's in here
is the um
of the one that had to do with uh
medicaid implementation in in new
hampshire and
the the role of that commission
elapsed and nobody had any uh thought
that that needed to continue so what the
bill has is its repeal and a lot of the
verbiage that you see in here is ols did
a really good job they had to go back
through existing statutes and just cross
out any references to a lot of these
commissions because
they weave their way in all over the
place so i know that there's some
language in here where that was removed
um
there was also a section on the
legislative youth advisory council did
that
i had spoken with representative
umberger about that we spoke to
representative walls i think she spoke
to representative edwards there was just
some language that just didn't make
sense with the way things are currently
operating so that was just
gotten rid of yeah
no there was nobody standing up
all right i think i'm set um thank you
very much for your testimony we
i think uh
we're good to go okay
i'm sorry to did you have a question
about the voter
id advisory panel i thought that was
coming up in oh okay
well i actually she mentioned it to me
and i did research on it so um
i went back
into our minutes that panel was created
in 2012 in connection with the adoption
of a voter id
law
and
we
repealed it at the recommendation of
secretary of state dave scanlon
and i called the secretary of state i
got off the phone with him maybe 20
minutes ago
and he said well the first point is that
the
committee is only convened at the call
of the secretary of state
and since
i mean almost since its creation they
haven't seen the need to call it and he
said the only reason that he would do it
is if there were voter id
problems at the polls and he said there
really haven't been i know there's a lot
of discussion about voter ids but the he
said for the most part people present
them and there really hasn't been any
need to call that panel and it was his
strong recommendation that we go ahead
and repeal it i mean the only other
thing that i would add is that you don't
need a
voter id advisory panel for the
secretary of state to look into the
issue it doesn't have to be codified in
law so if he wanted to look at it he
as he testified to us when we had our
committee hearings he reiterated that he
thought it would be fine for it to be
repealed and he recommended it
okay thank you very much sure thanks for
clarification on that point
um
i will grab the pink card here from
representative umberger
and ask
if she would like to testify for three
minutes she's speaking in support of the
bill
welcome to legislative administration
well
thank you very much uh for the record i
am uh representative karen umberger
i'm from the conway area
and um
i am very interested in
making sure
that we
have some sort of review
over
i believe that leadership the
the speaker
in in particular and deborah childs
um
because of all the work that she has to
do
believe that
somehow or other we have lost our way
and that
every single item
that has the least bit of
controversy
we create a study committee for
and
the result is this huge proliferation
of
deborah's book is about this thick
with
all of these committees and commissions
and everything else
and it has gotten to the point
where
she can't in many cases can't find
anyone
doesn't matter whether you're
in the majority or the minority
she just can't find anyone to serve
on many of the committees
and so my recommendation to her was
whatever person
put this bill in
is the one that should be in charge of
that committee and of course
they don't you know the
person that put the bill in is not
excited about that they want everybody
else
in the house to uh take care of that
but uh representative ebel had done a
tremendous amount of work
on trying to get
control
of what was going on and i think as she
explained
because of the problems and the
covet problems in the 18 to 20 session
that um
a lot of bills and this happened to be
one of them that really um never got its
its full due
so when we were talking about it
um i guess it was actually five years
ago
uh representative almi and i had worked
together
to
establish a group
a committee
to review the dedicated funds
because dedicated funds were
proliferating
in the same way
that
committees commissions councils you name
it are
continuing to proliferate
and so
what the bill did and what the committee
did
is that over the course of five years
we have reviewed
every single dedicated fund
and many of them have been eliminated
because
a they had no money in them
or b they had no purpose
and as a matter of fact there is a bill
that
we put together
[Music]
this year for the
decade of funds that are going to be
going away
and being kept and so on so that will be
coming up someplace soon
but i feel very strongly
and i believe representative abel does
as well
that if we don't follow through
and keep track
of what's going on with these committees
we are never going to get a handle on
and it doesn't ma and you know the the
other half of the problem
is that when the legislature changes
from republican to democrat or democrat
to republican
everything that has occurred
over the last two or four years or
however long it is kind of gets lost in
that transition
and so with this
with this committee on committees if
that's
to go through everything every five
years
it won't matter
who is in charge of the legislature
because this committee will continue so
thank you very much thank you um
are you
willing to answer entertain any
questions
uh i can entertain questions on some of
this but
most of the uh the bill dealing with
the things that have been repealed
occurred
while i was not in the legislature right
um
question i think from representative
greene
yes uh are there dedicated funds
mentioned
in this bill
i'm sorry no they're not
no because we have a separate
there's a separate committee that
reviews those it was just the model
that we use to come up with with this
okay
all set thank you very much for your
testimony thank you i have no other
pink cards but i don't know nope we're
good
um
with that i will close the hearing on
yeah 1309
um so i can open the hearing on
house bill 1309
and
call the prime sponsor that i think just
had a
pink card yep our representative gordon
welcome to
legislative administration speaking in
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is ned
gordon
and i'm not the prime sponsor of this
bill that's
uh representative wolf representative
wolf
uh unfortunately
uh had a medical issue today
isn't able to be here and he asked if i
would come and speak
about the bill on his behalf
the
the bill is very simple and purpose
and that is to
look at what might constitute an
adequate hearing
for the trailer bill
and from the genesis of this bill comes
through representative wolf but his
concern at least anecdotally that things
tend to appear in the trailer bill
and
sometimes somewhat surprisingly as to
its content and the question is whether
or not it's been
properly vetted
and properly heard particularly in the
house
we all
we all i think venerate
the idea that
the public should be able to have input
at uh on all all bills
and so
he put forward the idea and again this
just a follow-up following the exact
wrong bill to follow today but this is a
study committee
it would kind of create a study
committee i think the clerk just pointed
out to me that the study committee
has proposed is made up of house members
and senators and it doesn't seem
appropriate at all to have senators on a
bill with regard to looking at house
rules
and so i think
a much better approach would be to
have a committee perhaps of five members
of the house as opposed to members of
the house and senate looking at house
rules
i think that pretty much
does my two minutes in terms of a speech
i think the question uh it's very just
simply a question and that is is it
appropriate for us to look at what
constitutes appropriate public hearing
on the trailer bill
and
that's my testimony
thank you are you willing to entertain
questions sure sure i'm not sure i can
answer them but i'll be happy to
entertain them not sure we have any um
i don't see any hands up but i do have
one um
so is it your belief
now that
um
revisions made to
are inappropriate unappropriate because
they have
they have not had
is that
your contention
no i think my con my contention would be
uh that
the trailer bill should have adequate
public hearing and i'm not sure i know
what an adequate public hearing that is
where my next question and therefore i
think it would be nice for us to define
what would be an adequate public hearing
and i think that would in essence is the
purpose of the study committee
um thank you for your answer you're
you're not
indicating
here that
house rules would be put into statute as
a result of this this would
merely be
looking into it it's a committee that
would make a recommendation like other
committees
to back to
no
does it say report shall we findings for
proposed legislation for the speaker
president of the senate
house clerk
presumably you would be changing that as
well
um yes
that would have to change as well okay
um will you be taking up the amendment
i will advise representative wolf that
an amendment is needed okay
thank you very much i don't see any
sorry just uh just that i understand
things
um
so presently the rules committee would
oversee how the budget trailer is
handled
who would who would do that
i'm not sure that i'm not sure that's
correct in the sense that it oversees
how it's handled
the rules committee
ultimately will make a recommendation as
to what rules should be adopted by the
house okay thank you
good
thank you very much representative
gordon thank you for your courtesy
i
do have a pink card
from
representable uh
house clerk
paul smith
welcome again
uh thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee uh as as always i'm not
testifying in either support
or opposed to this legislation
i did discuss with one of the
co-sponsors representative gordon my
concern
uh initially with the drafting of this
bill that a study committee about house
rules would include members of the other
place
as you know
in the legislative process every bill
has a hearing
the budget
and
coincidentally the capital budget and
10-year plan
tend to change significantly from the
time of the initial public hearing
to the time of it being exported to the
body
uh i would note that our rules do
stipulate that before any action can
come
on
a final vote of the budget or trailer
bill a full
presentation has to happen to all house
members
um
i would note that
historically
the house
tends to not place
mainly
non-budgetary items
in
the trailer bill
that tends to happen as most of you know
in the aforementioned other place
uh it's not anything new it's been
happening for years
um
and i would just note that
uh i i think that
you you really need to consider
what can and can't come
from
this type of discussion uh the fact of
the matter is we can't control the other
place's rules
nor fortunately can they control ours
though sometimes they try
i would also note
that for those of you who work with
house rules or have worked with house
rules
historically the
any member
will approach the clerk and have a
discussion
about rules and i work with all members
regarding rules and rules proposals
whether or not i think they are a good
idea or not
it is my job to work with members in
implementing their ideas so that they
can present them before the rules
committee and ultimately
whether the committee agrees with those
proposals or not
and makes that recommendation to the
floor
so i would simply note that
i think a study committee to study
amending the house rules
if you want to amend the house rules
amend the house rules
i don't again as as we've discussed
before about legislating
legislative process
in policy i think that there's a means
to handle that within the existing
frameworks of the legislative process
so i would just note that
i think in the in these circumstances
because we cannot control the other body
that nor can they control us
um that
a if until a full and fair discussion
happens regarding rules and whether or
not that includes returning to the idea
of joint rules
which we have adopted in the past but we
that the odds of of changing the
fundamental process
of of the hearing and the disposition of
those bills i'm not sure how to
accomplish that uh
in in that kind of conversation
so
i just wanted
to err on the side of of caution in in
consideration of this legislation great
thank you very much uh entertain a
thank you very much for your
instruction
no other pink cards unless
anyone in the
listening audience wants to chime in
other than that
i will close the hearing on house bill
and wait until 2 o'clock for house bill
1368.
right on
i will uh
call house bill
house bill 1368
and asked the prime sponsor
representative gordon
to explain his bill to us
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
again for the record my name is ned
gordon i represent grafton county
district 9.
i also have another responsibility and
that is i chair the ethics committee
the
we just know
that the ethics committee has received
more complaints in 2021 than any other
year in its
existence
marketing
yeah we i guess we have to stop
advertising yeah
unfortunately many of them involve the
internet or
or social media but
um it's not our job really to police and
we don't do that but our job is to hear
complaints when they are brought to us
and we do address them
one of one of the issues that we've
discovered as
we've addressed those issues
is that
our
statutory format and our ethics
guidelines
do not address the issue of recusal at
all
and
i sent out or i had sent out this
morning a copy of this which is research
that was done and with
the
the law which applies to all of the
other states and virtually all of those
other states have provisions with regard
to
legislative recusal when people are
involved in issues in which they may
and i'll address that a little bit
further
our
statute our guidelines
do not address recusal at all
and
if you you were if you if you were to
read them you would believe that there
would know that there wouldn't be any
circumstance where you'd be required to
recuse yourself
the committee
in the past has found that there are
circumstances where recusal is
appropriate
where people may have some direct
benefit or work for an employer that has
some direct benefit but there are times
when
recusal is an appropriate outcome and
the committee has found that
and indicated that to people who have
inquired or have had complaints in the
past
so
the question is how to go about dealing
with that
and
we think that we need to uh and just
just in terms of background
uh
we uh our
our ethics guidelines were brought about
because we had a an issue here in the
house in particular
was somebody who was involved with
financially with someone and then
advocating for that party legislatively
and as a result of that the ethics
guidelines were promoted and our ethics
guidelines deal primarily with financial
interests
they don't generally deal with just
issues of behavior
although the house
at least the legislative facilities
committee has adopted a harassment
policy and discrimination policy and
told us that we're to reinforce that and
we have been doing that but for the most
part our ethics guidelines deal with
finding financial matters
but again there's no provision for
recusal so that what this bill tries to
do
is to
uh
identify the circumstances where recusal
would be appropriate i might add that
our constitution provides
for
recusal
in
part 2 article 7
it indicates that no member of the
general court shall take fees be of
counsel or act as an advocate in any
cause before either branch of the
legislature and upon due proof such
members shall forfeit his seat in the
legislature
so even as early as the late 1700s
there was a concern with regard to
[Music]
people having conflicts of interest
so this particular bill sets forth for
circumstances where it would be
appropriate for someone
to recuse themselves the first if they
have a special interest in an official
legislative activity
and special interest is later defined
but a special interest is something
where
you
would get a greater benefit than the
public in general a substantially a
substantially greater benefit than the
public in general
it's not intended to exclude everybody
right now if you have a conflict in this
state you just declare a conflict of
indicating that you have a conflict and
then you choose whether to participate
or not to participate well there are
circumstances where you shouldn't be
participating and that's when you're
going to get a substantial financial
benefit as a result of that or your
employer is
and
it
there may be circumstances and we've
discussed like current use right now we
have an issue with regard to current use
if you have property and current use
you may get a differential benefit but
it's not really
larger than anybody else who has
current use in the state and therefore
you probably need to declare a conflict
but you probably don't need to recuse
yourself for that
but if you were
to get some type of special award from
the state and that would be directly
paid to you or a household member
then you probably should be recusing
yourself
so if you have if an individual has a
special interest in official legislative
activity
if receiving remuneration from an
employer which has special
uh activity we had a
case
uh involving exactly that circumstance
and uh involved and god
may rest in peace douglas
which was published
where he was working for employer
basically being played and paid and
advocating for legislation and the
committee found that recusal was
appropriate in those circumstances
and that's basically what generated this
legislation
or if you're acting as counsel or
serving as an attorney for any party
which has a spencer special interest in
official legislation
so if you're acting for an attorney if
you're an attorney
you still have attorney-client privilege
but if you're acting as an attorney for
someone and they have a special interest
here you really shouldn't be voting on
there
on things that are going to affect them
directly
and finally if you're someone who serves
in an official capacity in an
organization
whether non-profit or for-profit which
is a subject of official
and that would be uh
which is typically being on a hospital
board
and
and all of a sudden there's a
legislation piece of legislation that
involves specifically merger of that
hospital with another hospital
should you should recuse yourself on
that
so
and
the bill is intended to deal with those
types of conflicts the types of
conflicts where somebody
or the person that they work for is
going to receive some type of
substantial benefit beyond what other
people would receive or what the public
would receive and they should recuse
themselves i sent this
out today
this is research that was done on
recusal provisions
is probably unlike most of the others in
that most other states
almost all the other states have recusal
provisions
but they're
like they're so broad they're
uh
if you read through them
if uh
a member uh where he accused himself
this is in kentucky if they have a
personal or private interest in any
we'd have a lot of people recusing
themselves a lot of the time in this
legislature
in maryland it's uh if someone has an
immediate personal
or financial interest
in massachusetts if it will
substantially impair their independence
of judgment they need to recuse
themselves
in michigan
a senator having personal private or
professional interest in a bill or
alternative measure
has to recuse themselves
in mississippi no senator shall be
permitted to act
on any question in his pri which in his
question in his private interest
distinct from the public interest
so you can see uh
as you go around the country they
virtually all estates have them and
they're very broad and what we've tried
to do in this bill is try to make it as
narrow as
we possibly can
because
we realize that there are lots of people
that have interests in various types of
businesses
that can afford to be here
if you work for an insurance
business for example
there are questions involving insurance
and unless you're going to get a direct
benefit from them you shouldn't have to
recuse yourself about insurance
but if it means that you're going to be
paid a substantial amount of money as a
result of some increase in premiums
maybe you should recuse yourself and
and so there is a difference so long in
the short
i think it's time that we put in some
type of recusal provision in our
first of all we've recognized already
that recusal is an appropriate outcome
for legislators in new hampshire
and i think there needs to be some
notice put in our guidelines as to when
you need to do that
that's my testimony great thank you very
much for your
complete testimony um will you entertain
questions certainly
representative simon
uh so just looking over this what is the
threshold or the kind of the limiting
factor for when somebody should recuse
themselves or shouldn't recuse
themselves
like is that for the ethics committee to
determine or
who would determine that kind of
well i think
i i
just like
i couldn't find in any of the states
where they have a specific threshold
standard like that right and
so ultimately
uh
ultimately i guess if somebody has to
make that determination it would be the
ethics committee and the way things
currently operate
and i don't think the as i said the
ethics committee isn't looking to
the ethics committee our ethics
committee isn't a punitive committee
what we try to do is is
educate legislators as best we can
and
there are times when it could be
punitive and
when it's totally appropriate to be so
but we try to avoid that all together
if we can
because
we know
the legislators here
are here because
they're not because they're making a lot
of money they're here because they're
dedicated and they're working hard and
they want to do the best job they can
and so
i think the la if it actually came down
to that as to what is a substantial
outcome i think
would give an advisory opinion from the
if somebody
should have recused themselves or it
came into question over whether somebody
should have recused themselves and they
did not recuse themselves that would i
would assume go before the ethics
committee and then the ethics committee
could or could not depending on the
circumstance
come up with some punitive action
against against the member depending on
how egregious it was or right if if it
was some if it was something obvious
you
you might
and
and for and they had notice
that there was a problem
and they went forward and did it anyway
um then i'm sure you know punitive
measures might be appropriate
i would say that the ethics committee
doesn't punish anybody
the only thing the ethics committee can
do is make recommendations
so we can recommend a censure or
reprimand or removal
but the legislature has to vote on that
okay
and
so uh
in that particular case generally if
somebody violated and they didn't do it
intentionally we probably would address
it appropriately without some type of
punitive measure if we thought somebody
violated it and they knew better at the
time and did it then
some type of punitive measure might be
recommended
thank you
and i suspect that's how it works in
roulade
hi thanks for taking my question
um
my question actually
is taken from page two
section five special interests
and it's the non-financial personal
interests that i'm going to ask you
about
so
we as legislators
have an awful lot of folks that contact
us that are considered lobbyists
that want us to vote a certain way
in exchange for
perhaps non-financial gain
promote supporting sending flyers on
your behalf
lobbying to get you elected
if you vote a certain way
on whatever it is is that considered
um
to the detriment or the benefit direct
i that may very well be a violation of
the current ethics guidelines
are
voting
if you have if somebody is calling you
up and saying i'm going to
send out a flyer on your behalf because
in hopes that you will vote this
that may have
implications that go beyond simple
follow up yeah follow up not necessarily
on that particular question but it
brings a lot of things to mind not only
with lobbyists but with other
individuals that
are requesting that you vote a certain
way
or there'll be
some issues that you have to deal with
is that
and you do vote that way is that
a violation of the ethics
rules that we're putting forward here
well
they're
this isn't meant to stump you yeah no no
no it's great i'm just trying to figure
out some of the things that happen that
you see
and now looking at the rules as written
could there be a
violation
per se
well if there's a quid pro quo i think
there's a violation so
if you're voting in exchange for some
type of benefit then you have a problem
if
if you are
you know typically lobbyists contribute
to campaigns they do that
they may talk to you about legislation
and and the benefits of legislation
and there's no quid pro quo
but if somebody is suggesting that you
vote in a particular way in exchange for
some remuneration
whether it be financial or otherwise i
think that's problematic thank you
further questions i have a couple
one is do we have a special
problem here um in new hampshire i'll
call it a problem or maybe it's an
opportunity depending on your point of
view um a special problem because we are
truly a citizen legislature we are
typically working in in another field
than
maybe other places that have dedicated
legislators is that
part of our issue or part of our problem
yeah
i i don't um
frankly i'm not sure that we have a
problem you know
so well we have more complaints this
year than ever so yeah well i think
anywhere i guess i'm saying do we have a
more of a
um
more of a difficulty in drafting
these types of when you shouldn't when
you shouldn't because we are in
businesses and and industries and every
other thing that
that touch
the legislation that we're working with
maybe that's a better way to say yeah i
think uh yeah and i and i think that's
right i think
that's why we might want to be more
specific as to when you have to recuse
yourself than a lot of these other
people who just say if you have a
personal interest in it right you have
to recuse yourself if we did that in our
legislature
we'd have half the body walking out
sometimes so um
so yeah i think that that probably
has
and i can't see how it's possible would
we ever get to a a time in place where
um
representatives at the beginning of the
session are handed
um
these are your recusal
opportunities and these are your declare
conflict opportunities i i can't see how
because it seems that every situation
as you just saw with
the discussion with representative
roulard
every situation has nuances and
and are subject to well it depends um
statements so
i i'm not sure that this is it's kind of
defining a cloud you know
it depends on
what we see at the time yeah
i
frankly as as as far as i'm concerned
it's sort of like the law
you know we pass all these laws here but
you get up in the morning you don't have
to read the law book to know what you're
supposed to do that day because you know
right from wrong
and
and as long as you
act right you
don't have to be concerned about getting
arrested or violating the law
and
i think that's true with the ethics
guidelines as well i think
if you have some concern
then you ought to qualify that and we do
get calls
questions all the time as to
whether that people should do this or
that recuse themselves or
or participate or
file the declaration forms
i can tell you
there are so many times when people
should be filing the declaration forms
they don't file the declaration forms
but we're not out looking for those p
we're not out looking for those people
um if somebody wanted to make an issue
potentially they could
but again we're not a police force
that's not our intention uh no but a tap
on a shoulder every once in a while and
say have you thought of this
may go a long way i mean i i i truly
believe in new hampshire and this may be
more on my soapbox than anything else
but i i truly believe
it's
it's omission rather than commission i
think we i think we're just
um
thinking we're doing all right and we
never gave it a thought i bet would be
the comment that most people
um when it's pointed out to them would
be saying oh gee i never even thought of
that
it is um
and i think it all comes back to this
fact that we have
our lives that are touched in so many
other places because we're still working
and we're still doing all of those other
things that
we're not just dedicated citizens
legislators
and
i can tell you that
of the complaints that we've received
this year
i don't
know that we received one single
complaint
that was specifically involving
a financial interest
virtually all the complaints
most of the complaints have involved
sign of the times
thank you very much i think we're set
with questions right your microphones on
um appreciate your time representative
gordon thank you thank you for your
courtesy
um
no others
i will then close the hearing
on
house bill 1368
and i think we've passed the point where
we can bring up um house bill
and i have
i thought
a pink card
representative wilhelm you may
take the stand whenever you're
able
representative wilhelm is uh supporting
the bill and says he will be speaking in
welcome to legislative and welcome back
to a legislative administration thank
you mr chairman
and good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is matt wilhelm
i proudly represent hillsborough county
district 42
in the new hampshire house covering
wards one two and three in manchester
as a former member of the house
legislative administration committee
great to be back uh this afternoon
and uh to pick up on some business
uh left undone from just before the
start of the pandemic
colleagues i'm here today to introduce
house bill 1370 which would establish a
committee to study child care options
for new hampshire legislators
a quick google search surfaced a 2008
interview
in the national conference of state
legislatures magazine
featuring the oldest and the youngest
state legislators in the country
perhaps unsurprisingly both were from
new hampshire
representative jeff fontes and then he
was then 21 years old and representative
angie kopka
then 92 years young
14 years later the new hampshire house
may very well continue to be home to the
oldest and the youngest legislators in
the country
according to the house clerk who can
correct me
if any of this is inaccurate at the
start of the
2021-2022 biennium the oldest house
member was 94 and the youngest was 19.
it's an impressive spread between the
oldest and youngest
and should be a source of pride for our
citizen legislature
we are consistent on that front and
definitely unique among legislative
chambers in the united states
but it doesn't tell the entire story
according to the house clerk with only
five members not reporting the average
age of the new hampshire house at the
start of the biennium was 61 years old
that's the same as last term
when you break legislator age down
further
the decade
with the most members
is legislators 60 to 69 years old
a total of 78 percent that's nearly 4
out of 5 members are over the age of 50.
to be very clear
i think there is a lot of wisdom and
life experience
in our chamber i know i've benefited
personally and professionally from the
guidance and mentorship
of our more seasoned house colleagues
including some of you here
just as i have gained valuable insight
but when the median age of our chamber
consistently ranks at the very top of
the charts nationally
i do think it's important for us to be
honest about areas where we could do
better so that our state citizen
legislature lives up to its promise
of being truly representative of our
state's population
when i first visited the state house as
a fourth grader
i remember looking down from the gallery
and thinking to myself i'd like to serve
in the new hampshire house when i'm
retired
but one of the main reasons that i made
the choice to first run for the house in
as a 36 year old with two young children
was that i felt like parents of young
kids were underrepresented in our state
legislature with our 100 annual salary
it makes sense
i also think about the challenges facing
new hampshire families health care
education
housing child care
just to name a few
i also think about the challenges facing
new hampshire employers
workforce attraction and retention
student debt and again housing
education and child care
and so for being honest
about where our citizen legislature may
be falling a bit short
i think it's important to acknowledge
that a barrier to public service for
parents of young children who would make
extraordinary
legislators is the lack of affordable
and dependable child care
recognizing some of the challenge that i
just outlined
facing new hampshire families and
employers i believe it would be smart
planning and good public policy for us
to do something to address this unique
barrier to public service in hopes of
increasing representation
of granite state parents the bulk of
whom are in their 20s 30s and 40s whose
lived experience is currently
underrepresented in the new hampshire
house of representatives
in 2020 the honorable samantha fox
introduced house bill
uh 1227 to turn the smoking lounge into
a child care lounge
and of course the child care piece was
somewhat tongue-in-cheek but it served
as a vehicle to drive a conversation
about the kinds of support that our
citizen legislature offers its members
in the 21st century
but in the days leading up to the
committee vote on house bill 1227 the
joint committee on legislative
facilities closed the smoking lounge
instead of recommending the bill itl
this committee voted to amend the bill
to establish a study committee to look
into child care options for lawmakers at
the state house which is essentially the
legislation before you today in house
bill 1370.
in the same way that installing the
mamava
pod the pod for new mothers to
breastfeed in private in the basement of
the legislative office building
it's a long overdue step in the right
direction towards supporting legislators
staff lobbyists and members of the
public with babies house bill 1370 is
another step in expanding opportunity to
the next generation of citizen
legislators
on monday we honored the life and legacy
of dr martin luther king jr which made
me revisit one of my favorite sermons
the drum major instinct
if you want to be important wonderful if
you want to be recognized wonderful
if you want to be great wonderful
but recognize that he who is greatest
among you shall be your servant that's a
new definition of greatness by giving
that definition of greatness
it means that everybody can be great
because everyone can serve
it goes on a little bit
but that last line is the one that i
love the most everybody can be great
because everybody can serve
sadly not everyone can serve in our
state's 424-member citizen legislature
raising a young child
should be a benefit not a barrier to
public service in new hampshire
our constitutionally mandated
legislative salary
of one hundred dollars per year forces
countless granite staters to pass on the
opportunity to run for office
for parents with child care needs
it can be all that more daunting to
figure out how to make it all work
as a consequence we miss out on their
unique perspective and lived experience
on a number of issues critical to new
hampshire employers and new hampshire
families
colleagues i urge you to send house bill
1370 to the floor with a strong
bipartisan recommendation of ought to
pass
so we can begin the important work of
better understanding the child care
challenges faced by parent legislators
and make recommendations to remove
barriers to their public service and the
service of other parents
in the years ahead thank you chairman
and i welcome your questions
thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for the
how about if i pick representative
nutting wong
thank you
um
would you believe
well first of all i'll start with i've
been a state rep as a
single lady and
engaged married and childless and now i
have a child
um would you believe that it takes my
whole family to make it work for me to
come here
um and serve in the state at the state
house my husband both sets of parents
it's a team effort to get my one child
care
uh thank you representative for the
question uh yes
uh i would absolutely believe that that
is the case and i also believe that
you're you're lucky and that you've been
able to figure out how to juggle and
make it all work and i know it probably
looks a little bit different each time
you come here
uh representative expedia
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative wilhelm for your
testimony uh my question is
do you know
uh
the percentage of you know
representatives now slash
and senators actually why not uh who
have you know have children or and then
that that being one and then how is that
in relation to the uh to the general
public here in new hampshire
uh
thank you representative for the
question uh i do not have that
information um
but
in doing some some research to prepare
for this you know i learned a lot in
doing some some digging
and um
i'm happy to look into that a little bit
follow up
thank you and i yeah definitely
understand if you don't know because i i
would you believe that there is probably
a discrepancy
between the number you know
the number of people who serve versus
thanks for the follow-up uh i would not
be surprised if that was the case
i have one
um
my question is uh
since the last time that we filed this
bill
garnered any evidence of
underrepresentation due to the lack of
child care do you
do you think that there are issues that
have not been addressed by the
legislature
as a result direct result of not having
child care
thank you chairman for the question
i think it's a really good question i
think that
because of the underrepresentation
of
folks that are in their late 20s 30s 40s
and i think that the data that the
clerk's office has has pulled together
and pulls together at the beginning of
each term
i think if you look at
how those decades are slightly
underrepresented
uh and you think about the
uh
the pressure then that
uh representatives
including some of whom are in this room
who are
doing that work of juggling
child care along with
working with
serving in the legislature i think it
puts a lot of pressure on those
individuals to
fully represent the the challenges that
are faced by those folks so i mean i i i
think there's anecdotal evidence you
know i think there's through
conversations that you know i've had
with folks um
you know this this makes sense to them
that we
you know pursue developing strategies
which could be a combination of public
private non-profit options that could be
on site here at the state house complex
or off-site
um
but i think it's it's worth pursuing so
that
you know those who do raise their hand
and say i'm ready and willing to serve
who are in this demographic who are
raising children don't have the
additional burden of
uh
of
trying to represent the issues faced by
working families
across the state
i guess i have two questions one is
comes from my experience serving on on
house education
where any number of times if i happen to
leave the room i would have to step over
three or four
um
i don't even know what they're called
anymore child carriers i guess or
something like that um
so so i guess i'm i'm leaning from the
standpoint of
um
you don't have to be in this place
you don't have to be a representative
to get representation
in fact i've told a couple people that
have lost elections i actually think you
can be more influential not being in the
state house than being in the state
house because you can focus on
any issue or several issues
and not have to deal with
other things
the other point that i'd like to make is
that it
it seems
a misnomer at least to me
um
i that
because of my age and
early 60s
i don't just deal with issues that are
relating to 60 year olds
i submitted a bill for
um
uh
people that
were unable to to
drive standard but were
driving alcohol for their older brother
or something like that i mean so those
are 15 and 16 year olds so i guess i'm
i'm saying i don't know
if there's a direct connection to
the age of the representative and the
issues that the representative is is
handling
so
i'm not trying to put this in the
category of would you believe i'm trying
to say
is it necessary in your belief
that
representation is a direct
relation to the age of the of the
representative
uh thank you chairman for a question and
i want to try and tackle both of those
situations um
to answer your
i'll start with number two first
i think
thank you
um
you know i think the ability to speak to
one's lived experience can be incredibly
powerful and one of the
things that i've benefited the most from
while serving in the house
is hearing from a diversity of
granite stater's experience both in
in public testimony you know members of
the public
and through really thoughtful questions
being asked by members of
each committee
and um i just started buttering us up
no but i just i don't want to understate
that because i think that the ability to
tap into your lived experience can be
really helpful and if you just
experienced something
earlier that day or in a previous month
uh in in raising children you know that
that can be uh
it can be really powerful question or
powerful testimony being shared
to answer the and not that it was a
question but your first point
um i would even encourage
the committee to consider an amendment
to broaden
the scope of
the bill to be beyond legislators to to
also think about members of the public
and the challenges that they might face
in
uh showing up here if they've got
children um and and i don't i don't know
what it looks like what i'm not going to
do is pretend that i know what the
outcomes or what the recommendations
of this study committee uh would be
however i do know that uh traveling to
concord
uh
you know outside of work and child care
and other
other factors can be can be challenging
for some folks i'm lucky i live 20
minutes down the road but i know some
other people have to make arrangements
you know
a week or two in advance so that it
aligns with the work schedule whatever
we can be doing to remove bears because
i think that what exists here in the new
hampshire house is just so powerful
where every
every you know representative can
introduce as much legislation as they
want
every bill gets a public hearing every
bill gets a vote i mean
our legislative administration you know
how it works
but whatever we can do to encourage more
members of the public to participate in
that process i think is a really
one one by representative one last
question it's an easy one i i you don't
have to think too much
this uh requires a finding and a report
by november 1st 2022 is that also the
date that you were going to terminate
the study committee uh yes thank you
you're welcome
thanks for the question
i think you're good uh thanks very much
uh good to see you again welcome back to
uh legendary administration um
i see no other
cards for this
bill
so i will close the hearing
on 1370
and
what's the time on
2 30. oh we're good right yeah
nope but we can go right into uh 1486
and recognize the prime sponsor
from earlier today representative reed
welcome thank you mr chair my new
favorite committee
ours too yeah i bet um so
i want to start
uh introducing this built for the record
my name is ellen reed i represent
rockingham 17 new market in newfields i
wanted to start by talking about
how proud we are of having a citizen
legislature and i honestly cannot do
nearly as good a job as representative
wilhelm did he was very eloquent in the
importance of a citizen legislature and
what that means and and to reference the
question that the chair asked him
about
well does someone need to be able to be
a legislator in order to be represented
and what does it mean because we deal
with all kinds of issues here
um
my answer to that and this of course has
to do with the topic of this bill
is no you you may personally not be able
or even interested in in
becoming a representative in order to be
represented that's why it's why we have
a republic it's why we have a
representative democracy but what's
important is that someone who
understands your issues is able to get
represented and if no one who
understands your issues is able to even
be be a representative that's where you
do not have a citizen legislature
for example i serve on fish and game a
certain percentage of this house hunts
fishes understands those issues
a certain percentage that
hopefully looks something like the
general public right
and in terms of being able to vote on
all the issues that are before us and
yes all the issues they're before us
there's a
panoply of issues before us that affect
a whole bunch of different people but
it's not that we take up those issues
it's how we understand those issues and
if we do not understand the average
experience of the regular citizen out
there if we don't have certain parts of
those that knowledge that experience
then we cannot be that citizen
legislature because we cannot accurately
vote on those issues it's not what do we
take up it's how do we understand and
how do we vote
so we are very proud of the citizen
legislature
and we want citizens regular citizens to
be here and and
we talk a lot about it but
we get paid 100 a year 200 per term and
this has had an impact on the
citizenness
of our legislature because what we've
ended up doing
is excluding
a huge portion a majority in fact of the
citizenry from being able to run and
that portion all have one experience in
common which is they cannot afford
to run for office
so all the working class people out
there who have to work to pay the bills
they are this this method of getting
represented is shut down to them
now yes the people here have already
worked in the past and and have those
but i'm talking about the experience
right now today these years the year
2022 what it's like to be a working
person in new hampshire and we have very
few people who are able to do that who
are able to run and represent that
understanding
i put it like this if i were to come to
new hampshire and start a business and i
want to hire 400 of the best and
brightest and most capable people in
this state and i say i can pay you a
competitive wage i would have a huge
pool of options
a huge pool of applicants to choose from
and i could choose the best and
brightest
but if i come to a state and say i want
to start this awesome business i need to
hire 400 of the best and brightest and i
can pay you 100 a year all of a sudden
that applicant pool has gotten really
really small and i may not be able to
find people who are the best and
brightest and can really do the job the
and the effect that that has had is like
i said is it it's not representative in
it's not just not representative in the
experience but then you see that play
out in other ways for example
um as of a couple of years ago the
average age of the the legislative body
is 66 the average age of the state is
43. it's just a different experience
there are other ways in which this body
looks different but let me bring you to
the original intent of that 200
that 200 that's in the
constitution that was put in 1784. in
the cost of one acre of improved land
having a structure built on it at one
acre was thirty dollars
thirty dollars is all it took to buy one
acre of improved land
you could take that two hundred dollars
and buy a six acre uh six acre farm most
people were farmers
or you could
live off that two hundred dollars but
the point is the intent of the
legislature the intent of the
constitution the people who framed the
new hampshire constitution was to in
fact
as the bible says pay the worker the
worker is worth his wages pay us enough
not an exorbitant amount not an opulent
amount
but a livable amount
to pay us for our time that we spend
so as you know it's in the constitution
and it's in the constitution the
compensation will be in full 200 per
biennium
and this was put in the constitution
before there was widespread
understanding of inflation so
i think it's fairly obvious that the
people who put this in didn't understand
that an acre of improved land in 2022
would certainly not be thirty dollars
in fact i don't think you can get it for
you probably pay more like three hundred
thousand dollars for an acre with with a
house on it right
so because that phrase in full it means
we either need a constitutional amend
well we need a constitutional amendment
we can't even put in legislation that
says okay we'll pay you the 200 but then
there's an additional amount that we can
adjust as the years go by for what makes
sense we can't do that because of that
so some people have suggested in order
to
afford i guess payment or compensation
and change constitution that we have a
smaller body and i absolutely disagree
with that i think that is the key to
citizen legislature the fact that i
represent only 3 400 people
there was previous discussion on the
previous bill about how
we many of us have to work multiple jobs
or try to make ends meet to make this
job work out i at any given time i'm
working several of
four jobs i balance four different jobs
in order to make this one work
i teach adjunct american government at a
community college i also drive for
boston duck tours
so i i
i talk a lot about the ideas of
constitution and government and good
governance
but we balance these jobs
but that means that i'm accessible i'm
in the workforce i'm talking to people
every day i'm driving when i used to
drive for public transit i have people
getting on my bus i hear the things they
say about their jobs and their
experiences i am accessible
that is citizen legislature
right that's not
you work for free because if you work
for free all that means is the only
people who can run are the people who
don't need the money that's not
representative but being out in the
public being accessible that is the
but i want to kind of focus on the idea
of compensation because the thing is is
we don't need compensation we don't need
compensation it says compensation in
full in order to overcome this problem
of we don't have a representative body
what we need is to enable the part of
the the citizenry that doesn't have
access to run we need to enable them to
run
so rather than try to adjust the
compensation by a constitutional
amendment or an unconstitutional
increase in our compensation
i have before you this bill
so how this works is this is a financial
assistance program that you qualify for
by being both low income and serving for
one year in the legislature
that is how you qualify for this
financial assistance program
it works by saying whatever the previous
year's uh average household income in
new hampshire was for any person who
served that year that full year if your
household income and it's important it's
household is underneath that average
you will qualify for a stipend the
amount of the stipend is either the
difference between your household income
and the average or a quarter of the
average whichever is less
so for example if the average income in
new hampshire for the household and the
reason it's important it's household is
i don't want to
pay you know an 18 year old who's living
off their parents right their parents
are doing well that's not the point of
this or you know
someone who's staying at home while
their their spouse is is doing quite
well
that's not the point the point is to
enable people who can't otherwise come
so that's why it's important it's
household it's also important it's based
on the previous years so that we're not
projecting what estimates of what
someone might make in the future years
so this requires that they have served
the year and it's based on the previous
year but i digress how it work i
explained how it works so for example if
the average household income in new
hampshire is sixty thousand and your
household as a legislator made forty
thousand the difference is twenty
thousand but a quarter of sixty is
fifteen so you would get fifteen
thousand because 15 is less than 20. 15
in that case would be the maximum anyone
um
so the whole point is for the body to
become a representative slice and if
that is successful if this were to be
implemented and became successful and
truly
this body started to represent or look
like in terms of ability in terms of you
know
your life and how you deal with work and
everything if we actually got to that
kind of parody then you would see
the income distribution in the house
mirror what it is in new hampshire and
based on that see i the fi the fiscal
note was indeterminate because they said
they couldn't
predict
who would in the in the legislature
would qualify but i'm saying if we get
to that parity we can predict because it
would look just like
the public
and so based on that and based on um
the percentiles that i got off of
statistic atlas actually on the
different household incomes in new
hampshire and it's just an estimate i've
actually i'm coming up with my own
fiscal note for this which it's not
cheap right but based on if
we look like the rest of the public in
new hampshire
you would have 212 senate and body
seven in-house you would have 212 people
who apply for some level of
of stipend some of those stipends would
be quite small like a thousand dollars
and based on those really rough um
income brackets
the total would be about two to three
million dollars a year so
not cheap not big in the grand scheme of
things but not cheap but i felt like i
should let you know that because they
didn't do their job and coming up with a
number
i didn't mean they didn't do their job
but you know what i'm saying i feel like
we can sort of sort of give an estimate
that's a worst case scenario maybe we
never get to parody i don't know
but
more to the point like in my
company
analogy that i gave
this i can understand people's reticence
in in supporting this as legislators
because what this means ultimately is
you're going to have more competition
people who cannot run for office would
be enabled to run for office and that
kind of sucks is sitting legislators
right like that kind of not the best
you'll have more competition but that's
how it's supposed to work
that's how we're supposed to operate
democracy
so
i guess with that i'm happy to take
questions that's the the points that i
have to make i know that you know i put
this in knowing that there would be a
push back but i felt like i needed to
say those things
great
thank you very much for your testimony
and i applaud you for actually making
your own fiscal note
i uh
you are willing to take questions i'm
looking at representative expedia
thank you mr chair thank you
representative reed for uh their
testimony do you think you know
do you think this would help in
also helping you know
get help helping the new hampshire house
become much more and
so diverse in terms of sex and race and
things like that i do because um the
percentages and these are just
statistics that women on average make
less money than men uh most racial
minorities on average make less money
than whites we are as a body
and i apologize in advance but we are
wider and
more male
as well as older than the general
population if we uh if we really looked
like the population in terms of race
then you would have about 20
representatives who were people of color
and we don't have anywhere near that um
that's five percent of the population
five percent of the body
but
um naturally
so this is not and also of course parody
for women we we'd have half the body and
i'm still hoping for that regardless of
the outcome of this bill but
um the point here is this is obviously
not directed at race or sex or anything
else i think you would naturally get
parody in all of those other categories
whatever they are if you enable everyone
to uh to serve if they have the skills
good
yes
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony today representative
i'm wondering with the department of
health and human services
who establishes the programs for
something like this is it done by the
federal government or does new hampshire
have the right to do it on their own new
hampshire has their own department of
health and human services in fact
they're here to testify that this would
be a lot of work for them and they would
really like you not to do this
so
and i understand that
and i've actually worked with
the the official who's here today on
other bills in the past and he's lovely
to work with so i won't take it
personally but now we have the ability
in my understanding to to establish this
through our own department and they
would run it
much the way that they run everything
else i will say that i do understand it
is extra work and everything we do here
means extra work for a department
somewhere um but this would be 212
applications so it is if we reach that
uh yes representative simon sorry
thank you mr chair thank you
representative um
so
not just yourself i feel like i've heard
it insinuated a few times um so i think
it's probably an important question a
pertinent question to ask
at this juncture um
well let me rephrase rephrase the way
that i was going to say it
one of the arguments that you made was
that people are unable to participate
because they have a lot of other
responsibilities that make them a part
of the community so for example yourself
you work duct tours and you um you know
teach adjunct and you're in those
positions because you're trying to make
this job work
if we were
to find a way to pay you more money
would that that
allow you i feel like the assumption is
that would allow you to not do those
other things so that you could focus
more here so would that then take you
out of the realm of rubbing elbows with
all of those people and make you less of
a citizen
legislator
well only if i mean so no i don't i
don't believe that because first of all
seventeen thousand as
based on the current median household
median in new hampshire
the maximum i could get would be
seventeen thousand a year so that
definitely does not put me in the i'm
independently well off and don't have to
work another job category so i'm still
working
and all my jobs are seasonal duct tours
teaching all of that so i'm i'm trying
to do things you know to make this
particular work so i'm always working
but i would say the people currently who
are not out there working by that
argument that you use are also not in
touch with the legislative with the
people so
so take my my position for example i i
own a business i i work
at least 60 hours a week as well as
doing my work here i have children i
have a wife
um
and i have enough money presently i
haven't always but i have enough money
presently to be able to support myself
um
but i'm still having to do all of that
work outside of here and be able to make
time
so what's the difference in that
scenario between me say and and somebody
who finds themselves in a situation like
yours for example once again i guess the
point that i'm trying to drive out a
little bit
is
if you were to make more money
and that doesn't alleviate your
needs to be a part of these other things
what have we accomplished in making your
life easier other than just getting you
more money oh sorry i
yeah i think i see where you're going so
it's it's not just simply the money it's
the it's the money spent for those hours
right so if i'm working a nine to five
if i am a normal nine-to-five worker i
cannot do this job everything we do
happens on a weekday in between the
hours of basically in between the hours
of nine to five it takes people who have
kind of creative or different or unusual
sources of income to be able to make
that work and yes sometimes at 60 hours
sometimes it's nothing but they can make
it work like i have all this kind of
little patchwork of of
seasonal part-time jobs you have your
own business so you can move your hours
around when you have to be here um other
people have other creative solutions
but the point is it's the hours
and if you are a nine-to-five worker
like most people a lot of working-class
people
then you cannot spend those hours here
one more
so to that point though
would this bill allow a person who's
working a nine to five
to give up their nine to five to be here
in your estimation that's what you're
saying it would allow them to give up
the nine to five because they would be
making
less than 17 000 now or
they can live on 17 000. this is
just trying to be clear yeah no it
allows them to go part-time okay
part-time okay thank you
okay
um one quick question um
what happens to those that are
generating
their livelihood or their income
by
municipal bonds or non-taxable
income i i guess i don't what are you
saying that doesn't fall under the
category of of their income right
i i
i
don't think i think it does fall under
the
have to ask category why do you think
that is an income
um
because it's non-taxable income so there
there may be represent if there are let
me put it this way if there are
representatives
that
would qualify for
this
financially
only because of the the
portfolio that they've put together
um wouldn't that be a problem i guess i
don't see where it stipulates it has to
be taxable income
um certainly if you put that on your
your income taxes and say this is
non-taxable income it's included in your
total income but it's not taxed right
it's it's not the portion that's taxed i
just wondered if you had thought of it
no i i honestly you're correct i haven't
i had not thought of that particular
problem but if you're in support of the
concept i'm happy to put a clarifying
amendment in
i just wondered if there was a thought
towards those that have the ability to
do things with their income
along the way i
absolutely uh do not want this to be
abused by people who have uh independent
ability to for living expenses thank you
all set
no other pink cards on this bill
i thought um i thought this was just
in case they were
um providing information okay
um yep speaking nuts not in support or
opposing but providing information so i
thought you were just here if we needed
you
i apologize um and and chairman hill
thank you and your committee i should
have made that more abundantly clear i
was actually expecting not only myself
for the record i'm john williams i'm the
legislative director for health and
services uh and i was expecting with me
rebecca lorton who is our financial
manager that assisted me in the process
of conducting the financial analysis on
the bill before you i do want to start
off by saying it's always been a
pleasure as well working with
representative reed she does a great job
i'd love to go on one of her duck boat
tours she's certainly i think we're all
signing up for that yeah and the fact
that she could distill my ethics problem
now though i think we've got so this is
the problem
and the fact that you could distill my
my commentary to the committee down to
two sentences i i applaud that that was
wonderful so with that said we actually
did a very thorough financial analysis
and one of the things that did obviously
not make its way into the bill which we
identified as part of our review was
that the average household income by the
u.s census bureau we went directly to
the census bureau to get this
information from 2019 was 70 of the
average or rather the medium average
medium household income in new hampshire
is 77 thousand nine hundred thirty three
dollars so around seventy eight thousand
dollars so i think that would be helpful
in looking at the calculations
when we said that it was indeterminable
we have no knowledge i know uh like
myself i'm required to file a 15a
disclosure
with the secretary of state's office i
know the legislature also has a similar
requirement to filing that as well but
it doesn't give us a basis of what you
actually make in terms of your income so
for us to say it's indeterminable i have
no idea as i'm looking at each of you in
this room i am i'm hoping you all do
well but i have no idea what you
actually make in terms of she does
really well
those attorney types tend to do that yes
they do so um as part of our financial
analysis we it is true that this bill
provides no appropriation whatsoever and
that raises all sorts of questions not
only because of the fact we can only
provide what you give us money to do and
this provides us with no money it raises
some constitutional level questions and
one of the things i would recommend and
it was part of our commentary in our
fiscal analysis on the bill but i would
agree with the legislative budget
assistance office that typically
constitutional issues aren't included in
their financial analysis so i think they
intended for us to come before your
committee to express what those concerns
might be
because in the current configuration of
this this stipend essentially would be a
payment from an executive branch agency
to a legislative branch it's not coming
from your budget i truly actually love
working with you folks and if there
wasn't a limitation i think you deserve
to be paid for what you do that's a
personal comment not a departmental
comment uh because i've worked with you
for many years and you do great work and
you deserve something more than dollars
but this is not the vehicle to establish
that and and the reasons why are as
follows when you think about the
relationship between the stipend and
giving money over to those people who
would those legislators and both house
members and senate members so this is
425 that we're talking about we would
have to do a financial review of their
their background and then you know issue
a stipend assuming that their median
income was less than the 78 000
for that prior year payment as explained
by representative reed
you would essentially
potentially be considered an employee
employer relationship with an executive
branch agency so i would suggest looking
to your your house legal counsel and i'd
make the same recommendation to the
senate if it passed over to that body
that in terms of the constitutionality
of a
executive branch paying the legislature
particularly since i come before you to
testify does on its surface doesn't feel
right and if it doesn't feel right you
should examine why that doesn't feel
right the other concern that we have
here is public impression you have held
very high the standard of being of all
volunteer legislators and you do a great
job with that
we have people who come to our agency
and there's no limitations you can be a
legislator if you meet certain financial
or clinical eligibility you are entitled
to receiving certain public assistance
from the department whether in terms of
temporary assistance for needy family
old age assistance snap benefits
otherwise food stamps and other kind of
resources you can apply for those as a
citizen of the state of new hampshire so
those benefits are out there they're
available to
the legislature as they are to all of
our citizens and
we have a funding mechanism for that we
receive partial funding sometimes from
the state partial funding from the
federal government but it meets with
with the federal constitutional muster
so to say
this would require i would imagine some
type of leveraging of general fund
dollars for us to be able to pay a
stipend to legislature where there is
nothing in federal law that would allow
us to leverage any federal dollar
matches for purposes of trying to
implement this particular bill
so i that really kind of concludes my
commentary over the concerns i would
just strongly recommend uh that you have
this reviewed by your house legal
counsel and if if there is any question
please put at least a severability
clause in the bill so if it is found
unconstitutional that there's a
mechanism to dealing with that um on the
other hand i'd also say if you think
this is constitutional you need to fund
this to be able to make this happen so i
think new hampshire does a great job i
do applaud the efforts of representative
reed she did a much better job with her
two sentences saying too much work
and it is true we would have to create
an i.t system new staff and we don't
have the resources not about not wanting
to do the work we don't have the people
to do this additional work that would be
required under this legislation so for
those of you who've heard from me in the
past i want to thank you for your
indulgence today and uh and i will take
any questions if you have any energy
this late in the day on your last bill
thank you for your testimony appreciate
you were looking at me i know you were
um
i was thinking when we were listening to
the testimony of the sponsor that we
were looking at an employer employee
relationship
and
as such we would probably also be
looking at all sorts of workers
compensation
claims
perhaps depending on
what else was categorized medical
issues
i don't know if they would be qualifying
for
any kind of pension state pension or
whatever it would be i mean it's all
questions that were up in the air so i
was thinking of that before you sat down
in that chair
but i do appreciate you coming in
talking about
public impression
i think that that is very important and
importantly i think that it is the
system the i.t system needed are you
saying that you would also need
additional employees to handle that
and of course i'd be looking to my
financial manager who couldn't make her
way here today but it would not be more
than one staff but i can certainly get
20.
she is not here um but my understanding
was it would not be more than one staff
to be able to do this but there would be
systems related changes and again no
funding to doing this the other thing to
mention going back to represent hilt and
it's related to your question is one of
the things we identified is whether this
is taxable i mean these are really
significant questions and to assume that
this stipend wouldn't be taxable
i would suggest not only um seeking
house counsel but you may want to seek
counsel uh from your tax attorney as
well
thank you
and there was a follow-up question um uh
chairman hill but i interrupted
representative
follow up no no
you're good okay thank you thank you
very much for your information you're
welcome
i think
um
we had there were there were two people
listed on that card are we
only
he's speaking for just okay we're good
so i can close the hearing on 1486
and i think this isn't a new for 1486
right okay
so um i am opening do we we are on the
right time right
aren't we
we have time for
is this three o'clock
okay all right
so i'm opening the hearing on house bill
1586 relative to the likeness of
wentworth
i've never pronounced this right
cheswell
at the state house and recognize the
prime sponsor
representative di lorenzo
welcome to legislative administration
five minutes she says okay
well good afternoon sherman hill and
members of the committee my name is
representative charlotte lorenzo and i
come before you to present
a bill um
that would um
allow for a portrait of wentworth
caswell to be hung in the state house
i want to tell you a little bit about
wentworth
caswell he was a resident of newmarket
mr cheswell served in the
revolutionary war
fought at saratoga
did sort of a paul revere's ride
in new hampshire to warn
the citizenship that the redcoats were
coming
he came back from
saratoga and
he served in many many
offices in the town of newmarket
including um you know town crier town
clerk
and throughout his life he served in the
community he funded the first free
library in new market
and
you know of all these wonderful
nobody in newmarket
in the in the 20th century had really
heard about him and about his legacy
fast forward to about 1990 a gentleman
by the name of richard alperin who was a
resident of new market was living on elm
street across from the
um
riverside cemetery in new market and he
noticed a sort of like a family burial
plot and it was a chess will plot and so
mr alfred became very curious about who
the chess wills were and he
started doing research on wentworth and
wrote an article in the newspaper about
you know mr
caswell um a couple of years later
mr albrin and his family
bought a home on elm street i mean on
south main street in new market and
again right next to his building that he
bought there was this family burial plot
and that happened to be the chessville
cemetery which intrigued um
mr alperin even more and so he started
researching um
wentworth had a roadside marker put
next to the cemetery and from there um
there's been research on his life
through unh students
and
about maybe about 10 or 15 years ago a
fellow by the name of john herman who
moved to newmarket and he was very
curious about the cemetery and we formed
a couple years ago we formed the
wentworth chessbill
appreciation society because all of us
in town or many of us in town 196
members of the society realize that they
wanted to learn about learn more about
this hidden figure and to honor his um
contributions and so
we are working on having a monument
built we're going to it's going to be
funded by the group a monument to one
earth chess well built in town
now i think that the important lesson
about mr cheswell is that
he was the first african-american
public official in the united states or
he was said to be
which is pretty remarkable his um
grandfather was an enslaved person
um
wentworth and his father were free
people
and
they were very very successful in
business in a town um
i won't elaborate there's more
information on this sheet and i can send
you more history about the chess wells
so
i'm ready to take questions if you folks
have them
ah thank you very much for your
i see one representative wallace
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my
in the bill uh the appropriation line it
says the sum necessary for the biennium
can we have a little more specifics as
to that i mean we're talking
i don't 20 000 we're talking 200 i mean
i i don't i really don't know
it's a little bit vague but i think the
folks who
doing the portraits would have a budget
you know based on comparables to what's
sorry if i couldn't answer your question
fully
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much for coming in with this today um it
says that the bill says that you're to
direct we are to direct the joint
historical committee to acquire and
display the likeness of wentworth to as
well
i am on that committee
we don't
acquire
uh we don't pay for these portraits or
anything
are you familiar with how portraits are
acquired
for the state i mean
i guess what i could say is the
committee
could accept it to present
in the process that they have to put
before the executive council to accept
it but what would be your first step
i don't know the mechanism i believe
that the governor would be able to draw
a warrant and then that warrant would be
approved but approved or disapproved by
the executive council
thank you
representative expedia
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative dilorenzo for your
testimony i
um
do we have any i'm just i'm curious do
we have any other
any other portraits of people of color
in the state house
not that i'm aware of
i can't say that there aren't because
again
there are many hidden figures in
you know in this state and in this
country
so it's possible that someone hanging in
the um hall right now could could be a
person of color that we don't know about
i have one or two
we actually have
a picture and and know what he looks
like
very good you know we have this i i
i don't think they want a portrait of
this you know
um so so how would
this portrait be acquired if um
it would have to be a composite i don't
think it would look like turtleman here
[Laughter]
i know that there are 40 right now there
are about 40 um descendants of mr
chessville in in new hampshire and
i think that
the right artist could probably do a
composite of um
a painting okay okay
second question i have is i this
the bill reads almost exactly like
the um
the day that was created um by the
i'm not sure whether most people most
reps voted for that day
as a salute to a revolutionary war um
person um or as a african-american or as
a town crier or a town clerk this is the
first time i've heard about the town
crier and town clerk
is there any record of him being a
state figure
because i'm not sure
quite frankly whether there are
portraits in the state house of people
that were primarily town elected
versus state elected i don't know if
that's a criteria i have no idea i'm not
sure about a state experience i do know
that he was a veteran of the
revolutionary war right
um
you mentioned his business he was um he
was in business is that listed in here
what what business he was in
well um
he owned he owned um
property in new market um the chessboard
family had a store
downtown
um
and then as far as his day-to-day work
he was a teacher
day to day he was a teacher yes i see
um
and and the monument that's being worked
on currently that is a town-funded uh
new market funded no it'll be privately
funded
privately funded for the library that he
donated to or
well the library um
that he donated to um i don't believe
exists anymore um because i mean that
was in like
17 something i read somewhere that he
had donated books to that do we know
that do we know what those
whether they were historical
uh significance to the books or do do we
know what they were i believe that what
he donated were his own
you know was his own work and then some
other work he was an author as well yeah
oh yes yeah he was a scrivener and an
author ah
beautiful scrivener beautiful work
excellent
um
phil's in my knowledge base i you know
just
um had not
had not run into it prior to the bill
and tried to gather as much as i could
out of this are there any other
questions that we have
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you mr chairman
and it's wonderful to meet you um when
you said that you were 62 years old i
just i was shocked really
so you're in good shape i'm not even
going to pursue that because i don't
know whether that was a good thing or a
bad thing
thank you very much
um
mr
address
the committee
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record my name is paul smith i
have taken a half hour off to be here as
a private citizen
to support this legislation
um the reason i am doing so is uh among
the many myriad of things and there are
a couple things that you uh may may not
have known um mr brother cheswell was
also elected to be a drafter of the new
hampshire state constitution although he
was unable to serve
the fact of the matter is
he was
a freemason
and i am an active freemason in the
state of new hampshire i've
served in the grand lodge of new
hampshire for several years
the grand lodge of new hampshire i've
just spoken with the grand master
we fully support
uh this this notion
on top of according to george mason
university brother cheswell is the first
elected african-american in the united
states
and that is
that achievement can't be taken away
from any place
he was not only was he an active
freemason in his lifetime he was a right
worshipful brother meaning he was the
master of his lodge and served in grand
lodge capacity as well
this was unheard of my friends even at
the time
if you if you hear anything about
freemasonry especially
you've heard of the term prince hall
freemasonry historically there had been
a bit of a black and white freemasonry
and and it's an unfortunate thing
and it's it's been resolved in in recent
years as with
many things
but
brother cheswell was
a member of the regular grand lodge
there was no schism in new hampshire we
didn't have separate freemasons in new
hampshire we've always just had the
grand lodge of new hampshire
i want to address the appropriation
issue for a moment
the grand lodge of new hampshire is
willing to fund this portrait
we are willing to cover it entirely and
have one of our artists
i i would just mention that there is a
brother who lives in the town of
merrimack his name is ryan flynn
and he was commissioned and he actually
just painted a portrait for the grand
lodge of south carolina of brother
prince hall in massachusetts and they
took uh period documentation um
from from his likenesses uh from uh
every every component of his of his
dress and i'm happy to share a picture
of that um portrait with you uh but i i
think it's extremely important to know
that this brother was an officer in the
revolutionary army this brother was uh
exceptional he was the first elected
african-american in the history of the
united states
and his portrait
belongs on the wall of the state house
there are there are portraits
and and some of you who are familiar
with the portraits in the states house
there's one in particular that's really
bothersome to many people and that's a a
certain person who who just donated his
picture and they hung it up and it's
still there on the first floor and i
know representative wall knows which one
that is because she's on the joint
legislative historical committee
um but i would just i would just note uh
that um you know the
the most recent uh portrait that was was
commissioned and hung up with us uh
marilla um oh gosh
right marilla ricker and uh that was uh
that was done by private funds and uh i
will note that the grand lodge of new
hampshire of of masons is willing to to
cover the cost of
of this type of portrait and we think
it's important it's a important part of
new hampshire history it's important
part of national history and i
again i i thought it was important
enough that i'd uh take time off
officially so that i could testify in
favor of legislation in front of you
today so glad you did thank you
um are there any comments
yep i just have a question for my notes
did you say he was the drafter a drafter
of the new hampshire constitution he was
elected he was elected to the
constitutional uh uh convention to to uh
to be a drafter and unfortunately did
representative speedy is giving a wave
he was yes
any other
comments questions
no
i think we're good thank you very much
for your
um
no other pink cards on that
i think i'm just looking at the number
now yep you're right um honestly i kind
of want to wave off because i don't
think i can come with that
yeah
well i can't i can't follow that so
um all i'll say is i am also being a
representative from new market in
support of this bill as a co-sponsor i
am so so so proud to represent the town
that wentworth cheswell called home
the first african-american elected to
public office in this country and now we
find out was elected to help draft the
new hampshire constitution and the whole
litany of accomplishments and i just
want to end with saying that um if if
the our idea of the american dream is
that no matter who you are no matter
what odds you might face that if you
work really hard and do the right things
that you can not just make it but
influence the world around you in good
ways then there is no person we should
honor more than him really because he
embodies that um
not just success on his own even just to
succeed would have been an
accomplishment but he changed the world
around him and helped form our state and
our country and i i can't i can't
do the clerk i'm sorry i can't do it
uh
with that i will close the hearing on uh
we're done close aren't we
here it is
ah
hcr9 um
which i need
ah
i don't think so
mr chairman i've been in touch with the
okay so why don't we just have someone
else
well we can take them out of order
because we don't really wanna so uh
representative wallace can you introduce
it
what
oh
um
the chair recognizes representative
well representative horrigan may speak
for 15 minutes
it's happened
um
representative wallace uh can you
introduce please uh house resolutions
concurrent resolution nine
thank you mr chairman happily uh for the
record my name is representative wallace
rockingham county district 12 town of
danville
uh this house concurrent resolution nine
is a resolution expression the
appreciation
of the general court to nicole knox for
and with that that's introduced thank
you very much for your testimony
um
well i would have had it on my phone to
play it had i been prepared for this but
uh that's fine i'll have representative
royce in that i'd like a pink card
somewhere
okay that'd be great
um did everyone hear that you will be
receiving written testimony from
yes that's right that's right
um
so representative horrigan
who is
opposed to the bill
speaking for two minutes
welcome representative oregon welcome
welcome very much i'm representing
timothy horrigan from stratford county
district six the towns of durham and
madbury and actually
um i'm in favor of the song it's
actually a nice little song and it's
representative wallace correctly noticed
it is on youtube
and
my
i've signed the pink card opposition
mostly i feel this is the wrong solution
to the problem that made the resolution
necessary and that's an issue that's
endemic
to our citizen legislature where we have
to work
do a lot of quick and dirty work with um
you know
with limited resources so this was uh
came as part of a senate omnibus bill
with several other rights maybe just two
other observances and
they were adding her song to the list of
state songs i think there's about 10 of
them the most recent one was it was
actually written by one of our
colleagues barry represent barry palmer
from nashua
and
these have never been controversial in
the past but they began worrying about
the copyright and some members of the
committee were upset that she might be
making royalties off it even though
those are oh she's a professional
songwriter that is how she makes her
living but
the
i didn't see a problem with they're
getting the royalties i just felt like
the correct
the correct way to deal with this would
have been to introduce another bill
making it adding it to the list of state
songs rather than um
rather than as resolutions although i
can't necessarily guarantee i won't
change my mind the resolution because
italians are making the floor because
um represent representative nicole knox
murphy is she's a very talented
singer-songwriter as far as to know
she's a very nice person
and she would
place in a rather awkward position by
this hearing they're supposed to be uh
you know routine and suddenly they're
arguing about like her making money off
the song and the copyright and all kinds
of really
um
i just felt like they should have uh
they should have probably recessed that
particular hearing and done more uh done
more research on it and this was in
another committee that you were not
sharing so i'm sure you would have
handled it differently mr chair so
that's uh
basically why i checked it off i
certainly have nothing against the uh
the song itself if you look it up on
youtube it's it's as i said it's a very
catchy song it's a lovely tribute to the
state of new hampshire and i'm sure
everyone on the committee will enjoy it
so
all set yes um will you accept a
question
no okay um i have one question yeah this
this um so you if i understood you
correctly you're saying that the correct
way
rather than doing a concurrent
resolution is
or is it a concurrent resolution still
to be able to add this
to
um one of this official state songs is
that what you're saying i don't know
whether we could i mean
you could speak is that what you said i
think you're just to put words in your
mouth i think just expressing your
appreciation so i'm not sure whether hcr
would be the way to add her to the list
of state songs which i think it deserves
to be on um
i mean you can try yeah you can try
writing it that way and see see if the
clerk and everybody else involves
if it passes muster with them but i
think
house bill should have been introduced
to correct the error or so
and fine i'm set anyone
thank you very much for your testimony
making a big fuss over nothing but
thanks for giving me like two minutes so
with that i will close the hearing on
hcr9
and
i think we're done
we went through i think we have now the
record
we went through 17 bills
thank you for everything
folks um as far as my understanding my
intention here
um
my intention is to um
begin the process of executing
these bills plus the cacrs
um
i'm hopeful that we have
more than just uh one two
seven of us um doing the lion's share of
the work here um
i'm hopeful that um we are able to split
the workload and so you know we're not
doing
multiple
committee reports as we go
the ranking member and i will have a
conversation i'm sure in the next few
days about where we stand on on some of
these and whether we can
i'm sure there's a number of these that
will be on consent one way or the other
but i um
i'm looking again at next wednesday
for
a morning
sorry about that um
for a morning you have hearings next
month next
wednesday
there isn't any really other day
that i know of that would work
um
so i'm going to suggest that we probably
will start seeing um
look in the calendar i'm going to try to
get it in for next week for
again nine o'clock
i don't know how long it'll take but i
think we should be able to knock it off
and then we'll be done um until
crossover
well before you get there we only we
don't
we don't own this room
we share this with municipal and county
and and
environment and ag
i don't know whether
i would have to talk with the other
chairs
i don't know have you spoken to your
caucus whether
even another day other than wednesday is
possible
okay
well i think we're gonna do what we are
gonna do
and
now we wouldn't be able to he's in the
building
yeah this is this is what we have this
is um
yes
but
well we'll
watch the watch for the calendar um
right now we're not going to solve it
here um it may be that i need to talk
with the speaker and the charity leader
we'll talk
okay um that's all i know for now
everyone drive carefully home um
start looking at these things as
um
which ones you're willing to volunteer
for
okay
we need um we're gonna we're going to
don't make me get to the assignment
process so um that's that's as far as
i'll go thank you very much for
everybody
you